If you hear those clicks, that's
me typing. Ladies and gentlemen,
I'm not the fastest typer in the world.
I get it done.
Uh, this episode of the podcast
is brought to you by blue apron.
Blue Apron is one of my newest and most
favoritest. That's not a real word.
Um,
sponsors because would essentially is,
is they send you all the ingredients
for healthy meals and you cook them
yourself by their directions,
uh, with their recipes. Uh,
all the portions are measured out
perfectly along with spices and a detailed
photographs that show you
what to do and uh, all the,
the various parts of the recipe.
It's really interesting and it's kind of
fun too cause cooking, you know, if you,
if you get like a recipe book and
then you have to go to the store,
you have to buy the
individual ingredients,
you have to measure them and weigh them
and all that stuff that that's a lot of
extra work.
That blue apron sort of cuts out and
they also provide you with a wide variety
of different meals to choose from, which
makes it, which makes it interesting.
It becomes like a little bit of a project,
which I think is fun. Um, but really,
really yummy foods like coconut
curry, salmon steaks, um,
Swedish meatballs with braise,
Kale, stuffed cabbage rolls.
I've eaten several meals from them so far.
They,
there the amount of calories that
you get from these meals. Also, it's,
it's pretty surprising.
It's 500 or 700 calories.
It's just very low for a really yummy,
delicious foods,
but they're all prepared and designed
by people who really know how to make
Yummy, delicious food. Uh, it's not
hard to do. I'm not a great, great chef,
obviously. Did I have to say that?
It's like saying I'm not a doctor. Uh,
I'm not a great cook. I know how to cook
a few things, but this blue apron thing,
I find it fun. I find it like a
little bit of a project. You know,
it's a lot cheaper than ordering out.
You can get everything is
$9 and 99 cents per meal.
That's all the ingredients in the exact
right proportions with simple recipe
instructions right to your door.
And like I said,
there's a wide variety of things that
they're going to send you and things to
choose from. It's really delicious. It's
very healthy for you. Incredible meals.
And uh, I think you'll be blown away
by the quality and the freshness.
All of it comes in like this.
A Styrofoam container all sealed up with
ice bags. It's a w whatever they use.
Ice Packs, frozen things, dry eyes.
So what it is, yeah, I'll let shit,
whatever the stuff they use to keep it
from rotting. That's what it really is.
But it's delicious.
Go to blue apron.com/rogan and
get your first two meals for free.
That is blue apron.com/rogan and
Really delicious. I'm, I'm really happy
with it. I use it all the time now and uh,
I, you give it a shot, especially when
you get your first two meals for free.
We're also brought to you by legal zoom
legal zoom.com is a way where you can
handle a lot of stuff that you would
ordinarily have to go to a law office for.
You can handle it all online and everybody
knows that anytime you have to deal
with any office where you have to
make an appointment and go there,
that's a huge pain in the ass.
You have to take time off work.
You have to figure out how to get
there during normal business hours.
There's a lot of things that people
take care of in law offices that you can
take care of.
With legal zoom,
self help is the way to go
with all these different,
like for the longest time, like there's
so many different parts of our society,
of our civilized world that you would
have to go and talk to an expert,
make an appointment, spend an exorbitant
amount, exorbitant amount of money,
paying this expert to deal with Shit you
could do with all sorts of legal things
on your own, like a power of
attorney, get a will, living trusts,
forming an LLC, all that stuff.
It's super easy to do on legal zoom.
Legal Zoom also has an a plus from
the better business bureau, which is,
it's a huge relief if you're dealing
with some sort of me like what are they
doing? They're fucking, what are they
doing? They're legal help online.
What it sounds like it could be shady.
Legal Zoom has helped tons of people.
We know so many people that have used it.
It was originally used to start on
it. Uh, Brian used it to form a desk,
squad.tv. The LLC for that. Um,
Tom Segura and Christina Palicki,
I think they use it too.
It's really easy to do any more on who
knows how to just fill out forms can do
it. And if you get into a
panic while you're doing it,
they can connect you with a third party
attorney. Legal Zoom is not a law firm,
but they provide you with self help,
legal services at your specific direction.
And like I said, if things feel
like they're going horribly wrong,
legal zoom can connect you
with a third party attorney.
It's super easy to deal with
ladies and gentlemen. And very,
very economical as well.
And for a special savings,
be sure to enter Rogan in
the referral box at checkout.
So go to legal zoom.com you can even
get divorced. How about them apples?
And probably not though.
Let's be honest,
most of the time when people are getting
divorced, there's like a little, there's,
there's a little gamesmanship going
on. But if you are, if you're amicable,
if you'd both look at each other and go,
let's just fucking end this.
You'd go to legalzoom.com and
take care of it anyway. Go there.
Use the Codeword Rogan in the referral
box at checkout and save yourself some
money. That's legalzoom.com. Do
you like my new song? Very good.
Thank you. Yeah, don't
use that legal zoom.
I'll write a better one for you anyway.
Emily and Vincent are here from Buddhist
Geeks and uh, let's just get cracking.
I fuck around legal zoom.com
musical were Brogan.
Okay.
Experience.
I got to figure out a better way to do
commercials cause it's always weird with
two, two people at a three
or just sitting there
and one person is talking
to doing a bunch of money.
It creates an uncomfortable air in the
room. I'm all right a little bit. Right.
It's a little odd. Um, Buddhist Geeks,
somebody sent me a link,
I guess it was probably a couple of
weeks ago on Twitter to you guys.
And right away I went, oh,
this could be interesting.
A convergence of what'd you say?
Spirituality,
Buddhism and technology.
That's what you see and Geeks which
always is somehow are connected with um,
impairment and vision, which
is very strange, right?
Like being very studious and intelligent
is connected to your eyes are fucked.
Like every, you know, I mean you're
looking at screens all day, I think.
Is that what it must be?
Right.
Because as I've spent more
time in front of a computer,
my eyes have steadily gotten
worse. Um, but your, your image,
the logo is the Buddha with glasses on.
So even the divine are not immune to
the perils of LCD screens. True enough.
Is there a better way
around this to, to, uh,
to do something where it doesn't
completely destroy your vision?
Maybe clairvoyants get developed
that capacity. That's the only way.
But reading does it too,
right?
Cause we've always associated reading
with or is it just getting old and we're
just blaming it on a bunch of other shit.
Could be that, but I, I think it's
staring at things up close. You know,
there's just,
I think the eyes just get used to staring
at things up close and then they can
just can't see far away anymore.
That's my theory with me.
It's the opposite though. My up close
vision is starting to suck my, my vision,
like looking at you guys at this
distance is fine. It's perfect.
That might be age then.
Yeah,
taking the age because also because
when I put on reading glasses, um,
things just get sharper. I'm like, oh,
that's what things really looked like.
You know? Like, I could read
everything without the glasses,
but then when I put them on and see like
the, like if you know, you look at pages,
you can see the actual detail,
the texture and the paper itself.
That's all gone to me.
That's all gone in the real world.
What is Buddhist Geeks?
What are you guys doing?
Well, we started, um, several years ago
as a podcast doing this kind of thing,
talking to people and I'm really,
in the beginning it was just my sort
of early twenties rebellion against the
Buddhist tradition.
And I wanted to talk to people that
weren't part of the mainstream Buddhist
world, but had something
cool to say. I thought.
So we've just basically started by
talking to some different rebels,
a lot of Gen Xers who
are kind of coming up as,
as teachers and um,
meditation experts are masters.
And it sort of started there just
as a kind of whim project, uh,
with a couple of friends
and then people responded.
So he kept doing it and we felt a sort
of obligation to continue exploring
Buddhism, technology, culture,
the way it's globalizing.
And we just sort of from there, I've just
been on a sort of eight year odyssey,
uh, and Emily recently,
about four years ago,
kind of join the team and we have visited
in the mom and pop thinks and I love
it. I love that that Buddhism
has rebels. Absolutely.
What is the main,
what the main thing that people fight,
not fight against but rebel
against with Buddhism?
I think it's like most religions,
you know,
there's some aspect of just rebelling
against people telling you what to do or,
or the feeling that,
you know,
this system of beliefs is telling you
how to live or what to do with your life.
I think that's part of it is just kind
of breaking apart dogmatic structures and
sort of saying,
hey,
actually we can make this our own and
figure out how to do it ourselves because
we're the ones that are interested in it.
So we have to sort of take ownership
of that. And so there's a bit of like,
I guess generational pushback, you
know what I'm saying? Actually,
we don't want to meditate like
the hippies dead, you know,
we don't want Lotus flowers and incense,
you know,
we want like our computer screens
and meditation apps. You know,
we want to do it the way
it makes sense to us.
What is that an effective way to do
it? Like Meditation Apps? Is that real?
Is that legit? Are there like
some recommended meditation apps?
They was better than traditional forms
or an alternative I should say to
traditional forms of meditation. I think
there are, yeah, there's some good ones.
I think they're good to start.
I mean as soon as you start really getting
into it though, then it's useful to,
I think still meet space has the upper
hand over the APP space. Interesting.
Yeah. But I, I'd recommend beautified.
That was one that Emily and
I contributed to. And it's a,
it's a modern mindfulness on the go APP.
So it's sort of teaches you how
to meditate in different contexts.
Like if you're at the gym or if
you're, you know, on the tube. Um,
you wrote one for working on the computer.
Yep.
Never heard a couple of her
working on the computer.
So it's really just about trying to bridge
like what we're doing already in our
lives with a meditation practice and
these ancient traditions that have come
down.
What do you, what is the APP for working
on the computer? What does that entail?
Beautifies the APP and then the
couple of meditations that I wrote,
it's just simple things like I'm bringing
your attention to different kind of
anchor points.
For example,
you know we all usually have some sort
of touch screen mobile device and so you
know, you can use your, use it to bring
your attention back as you swipe it,
you know, back and forth with your
finger. So it's just something, you know,
it was very simple to
return to so that you know,
consciousness and the mind can
start to just kind of settle so that
you're more aware and five being more
aware. It makes a lot of difference.
When you say more where you mean,
um,
cause a lot of people kind of scattered
there. They're all over the place.
And Dave took one minute.
They were on, you know,
all kinds of different apps. Do you
name one? Is Facebook the devil?
No, I do sometimes. Yeah.
There's no meditation in Facebook
though. Correct? Not yet. Not yet.
What I think Facebook's into it,
it's a fascination with
social interaction. Right?
That's what it is. It's just
this thing where, you know,
I read this piece was talking about
the origins of gossip and what, what,
what gossip is all about,
why so many people are into
celebrities and celebrity gossip,
the Kim Kardashians stuff
and that kind of thing.
And the big thing being that our
culture doesn't have the same sort of
communities that it once had these
tribal bonds that expanded from 50 to 150
people to cities of 30 million.
They're,
they're very confusing for our biology
apparently. Absolutely. And so, uh,
that's why people gravitate towards what
seems to be really a name like this,
this, this pull towards, oh my God,
she left him and he went up
with her and oh goodness.
You see those magazine covers,
you just want to grab them.
And people who have no
part of your life at all.
You shouldn't be caring about them even
remotely, but for whatever reason you're,
you're compelled to do it.
This is a little bit of that
with the Facebook thing.
Right. I totally agree. When I
read a great article that said,
in some sense Facebook brought that
experience of living in a tribal village
back as a technology.
Marsha Mcluhan and his whole sort of
theory about every technology brings
something back from the
past. Yeah. Mcluhan has,
one of my favorite all time quotes is
that a human beings are the sex organs for
the machine world. Ooh, Ooh.
Yeah. That's the greatest ever,
right?
That is one of the all time greatest
quick JBS Haldane ains not only does the
universe queerer than you suppose
it's queer than you can suppose.
That's my number one favorite,
but number two right up there.
Nice cause it is a, I mean McLuhan was
right. What are we doing? We're making,
we're making computers and we keep
making better ones and we keep,
we were essentially the evolutionary
device that that causes the,
the,
the things that we've created
to accelerate far quicker
and innovate far quicker
than biology ever has a chance to.
And in the process, we're also,
it seemingly,
at least on the verge of creating some
sort of an artificial biological life.
Some, whether it's biological, I mean,
I don't know what you call artificially
created cells that interact with each
other the same way human cells do.
But we're pretty pretty God damn close.
Whether it's a hundred years or 200 years,
pretty close to making artificial people.
And where's that coming from?
It's coming from people. If they
are machines, biological machines,
McLuhan,
we'll be right.
And then a new life form will be
birthed out of our greasy little hands,
not ours, obviously. Yeah,
I think that's right.
I saw Elon Musk on Twitter a couple of
days ago, said, uh, increasingly looks
like we're going to be the biological
boot loaders for a digital super
intelligent.
Yeah, most likely there's a
bunch of people that don't
believe that's happening.
I read this interesting
article on Kurzweil.
The guy was very critical of
Kurzweil and uh, he was, uh,
I think this guy is like sort of,
um,
he's a curmudgeon a bit.
He's an intelligent guy.
But his criticism of Kurzweil was
basically a biological criticism of that.
Our understanding of the
human mind is already, uh,
it's fairly limited in terms of like
how the human mind processes various
hormones and neurotransmitters
and proteins and that are,
there's no way we'll be able to recreate
that because our ideas of human,
of the human mind,
the biological mine are still constantly
evolving and changing and growing and
that we're not really ready yet
to duplicate the human mind.
But my take on that was that we,
we don't have to duplicate the biological
functions of it to duplicate the
actual functions of it is if they figured
out a way to make something that not
only mimics the memory banks or the,
the,
the memory access of the human mind,
but is much better than it does it
in a completely different way and non
biological way.
And they can figure out a way to download
intelligence or download consciousness
or memories into that bank. Well,
we're not going to really need this,
this whole idea of cells and proteins.
And I mean that that is,
those are the components
of the biological machine.
But if we can make a
better version of that and,
and do it like some sort of a synthetic
version or some sort of an artificially
created version,
it doesn't seem to me that we're going
to need to know everything about the
human mind in order to
recreate its processes. Right.
Does that make sense? I
mean, it makes sense. I, uh,
I feel like I'm not enough of a specialist
on artificial general intelligence to
really know the different, the
problem is, I don't think anybody is,
I mean, there's a bunch of people
that are working really hard at it,
but no one's ever done it. So if
you haven't done it, who's the hell?
How the fuck are you an expert?
I mean if,
if there's not an artificial
human being that is, um, you know,
state of the art version 7.0,
uh, capable of compassion,
understands its actions, hopefully
it will be, well, it has to be right.
Otherwise we're going terminator
style. That's right. Right.
That's the real question now.
Sort of like the way we did nuclear
power before we learned how to shut off
nuclear power plants.
Like I hope they don't do that with
artificial intelligence. Like, wow,
let's just get this thing up and
running and then we'll figure it out.
A way to give it emotions.
Mm. Yeah. No,
I mean that's what scares me a little
with the AI stuff is that it's so much
focused on the rational thought
process and yet, you know,
my experience of being human is that
that's barely part of my human experience.
Occasionally I'm rational,
I have thoughts,
but mostly I'm just like reacting to
things and emotional and, you know,
I don't even know what, what it's
running most of my processes. Yeah.
That is an issue.
Right?
Yeah.
And I think it's also interesting to
see just bringing a little bit of the
feminine perspective and it's like,
I'm very conscious of like, you know,
childbirth and some of these pro,
you know,
natural things that are on my mind a lot.
And so thinking about merging
the technology or creating
some sort of artificial
intelligence,
it seems to me that a lot of these
conversations start to navigate really
quickly towards getting out of
the body. And so I, you know,
wonder if there is some sort
of bridge between, you know,
we're going to create something new. And
at the same time, like you were saying,
like infusing that with wisdom and
compassion and some of these biological
processes. Are we ever really
going to get out of that?
I don't know that it's just an
underlying assumption a lot in these
conversations that I think is interesting.
Yeah. It's fascinating because the, the,
the general idea of
the human body and the,
the needs of the body,
whether they're the needs for food or
the need for the human touch of the need
for, uh, the need to breed,
all these different things will be
completely unnecessary if we're no longer
biological and what,
what is causing war?
What is causing greed?
What is causing jealousy are these
ancient monkey ideas that are stuck in our
genetics, these mechanisms that have
sort of forced us into the future,
that forced competition.
They forced us to cope and adapt.
They forced us to learn to
interact with each other. And this,
along the way we've
sort of developed this,
these methods for managing the biology
and meditation being one of them.
Meditation and mindfulness and trying to
be centered and being the president has
sort of emerged because so
many people are like, wow,
am I fucking head's all over
the place? And this is, hey,
this is what I've learned. If you just
do this and say, this is where I am,
this is what I'm doing.
All of this stuff is nonsense.
I concentrate on this and this
I can get things done with.
But if I live in the past and worry about
all of the mistakes that I've made and
allow them to define them,
allow them to define me,
rather they can be very limiting and they
can really ruin your perceptions in a
sense or flavor. Your
perceptions in a very, uh,
a unsatisfactory or a very
unwelcome way or your,
your day can be burdened by the past
or you could be in the PR like these.
All these things are sort of designed
to allow us to navigate the biological
waters, right? To, to figure out what
is the push and pull of this machine.
Like why is this machine jealous?
Like what's going on here?
Why is this want me to be upset
at someone else's success?
Why does this want me to be upset that
someone is attracted to someone else
other than me?
Why does this want me to be upset at
someone else's house or someone else's,
you know, family or whatever it is
that is tweaking you. What, what's
going on in here?
Well,
it's the machine wants competition
because the machine has gotten you to 2014
where a million years ago a monkey crawled
out of a hole and a figured out a way
to draw an Arrow that points towards
where the food is the other monkeys.
Oh that way you could be like,
aw, I see what you're doing.
And then those ideas compiled
and they piled on to other ideas.
And before, you know, what
a million years later,
we have a civilization and complex
civilization that has all these different
influences that have led us to this point.
But a lot of them are biological.
A lot of the,
the very motivations for doing most of
what people do on a daily basis are very
biological.
When those are eliminated,
it becomes a real question
of like what's life,
what exactly are we?
And if we reproduce through test tubes
or whatever the hell it's going to be,
you know, when we become more, you know,
three d printers or whatever it's going
to be when we become biological, um,
copies or artificial biology,
like what,
what are we and what is life?
Yeah.
Those are really important
question gas. I guess. I think
one thing I thought was interesting
as I got into the transhumanist stuff,
you know, while back was that, you know,
they use this term mind uploading
to kind of predict, you know,
we'd be able to upload our consciousness
into the cloud and stuff like that.
But I thought it was interesting that
later I realized they never then use the
term body downloading.
So why is it that you can upload your
mind to the cloud but you can't then
download your consciousness back
into different kinds of bodies.
And I think it speaks a little bit to
what Emily's saying, that there's a lot,
a lot of the shadow of the geek culture
is a disdain for the physical body and a
disdained for limitations, which I
totally understand because you know,
I think there's part of us that wants
to transcend the limits of being human.
You know, and it's the same thing that
drives the Buddhist meditators to seek for
enlightenment in its to realize this
thing which is beyond in some sense the
limitations of the human
experience. And yet, you know,
the real mature expression or realization
in the Buddhist tradition is to
realize that and then to return back
into your incarnated physical form and to
fully inhabit it.
So I hope that the transhumanists in the
folks that are building these, you know,
seeds of digital superintelligence realize
that even if we're able to upload our
patterns into the cloud, we still, if, if,
if they're still beings who have
a sense of, of themselves and,
and have some sort of physical substrate,
whether it's carbon or silicon,
that they're still going to have to
deal with certain issues of incarnation,
of being in a form of
physical form of some sort.
Even if it's a very loose digital,
you know,
very fast flickering at form,
they could still,
there's still something there and there's
still some sort of reference point.
And I think that's where the Buddhist
tradition has something to say,
even about super intelligence and
what that experience would be like.
Because as long as there's a form and
as long as there's an identity, right,
like a reference point, uh, me,
then there's going to be certain kinds
of issues that we can't get rid of.
Like then I have to deal with you and
have to deal with these other youth.
And I then there's things are objects
outside of me and some of them I want and
some of them I don't want and some
of them are just going to ignore.
And so even if I were a
superintelligent consciousness,
which I can't imagine because my
imagination so limited, um, I,
I still think there will be some amount
of fundamental dissatisfaction that's
built into the experience of being
an individual who has a reference point.
And I think that's in some sense what
the Buddhist path is about seeing clearly
is that most of our existential
suffering and despair comes from this
fundamental experience of being a separate
being who exists on this side of my
body.
But isn't the experience.
I mean if you really stop to think about
true enlightenment and being completely
and completely in the moment,
it doesn't that exist in the
animal kingdom exclusively.
I mean that's the only way they exist.
They exist completely in the moment in
a sense that is the most biological of
all creatures and that that's a
creature that has no existential issues.
They,
they don't have any angst in terms
of their future or their past.
They, they, they live and
exist completely in the moment.
So isn't it just our awareness of
the futility of this existence?
That's part of the problem because
along the way we're innovating,
we're expanding, we're growing, we're,
we're doing all these different things.
We're going to biohack and conferences
and whatever the hell you're doing.
But at the end of the day,
you live and you die.
You have a very short
window here and it's like,
what are you supposed to be doing,
I suppose to being joining it?
I supposed to be leaving it better for
the people that come after you and what's
their poor purpose? Like why leave
it better for them? And what,
what are they doing? They're just
leaving it better for the next,
at the end of the day,
what are we doing?
We just enhancing this giant
super organism known as
the human race and for what
purpose? Because we're helping it pollute
because we want more planes in the sky.
We want better cell phones.
Like what? You know these, this,
the existential angst of being,
of being conscious,
of being able to recognize that this
is kind of like at the end of the day,
like what? This is just a
weird little trip you're on.
You know you're on a
birth to death trip and
if you become something that's not human,
if you become something that's
not burdened by biology,
is not burdened by sexual urges or,
or any of the petty urges of,
of modern human and a life that we
all struggle with. What, what exactly are
you here for? What exactly is going on?
And motivation might be the number one
problem with artificial intelligence and
it might not even be compassion.
It might be that artificial intelligence
becomes so intelligent. So it's like,
what the F we're not doing shit. Okay,
I'm not doing nothing. Why would I
do anything? Like why would I expand?
Why would I move on? Why would I make
more of me? Why would I do anything?
Why would I explore galaxies? I
don't even have ovaries, you know,
I don't have a mind.
I don't have a sense of of futility.
I don't have a beginning and an end,
an end.
I can make another one of me with
a button like what am I doing?
Am I going to go see the top of,
you know, the Grand Canyon for what?
For what purpose?
What am I going to,
I'm going to get fly in a plane and
go to Paris. Why? What do I go? Shit.
I don't have any desire to learn.
Like there's no urge to improve and
innovate. I'm not biological anymore.
Like what is created? Everything that
we have, everything that we have, every,
every building that we've ever made,
every work of art that we've ever created
is essentially this thing inside human
beings that wants us to
innovate and create this, this,
this thing that has allowed us to
radically reshape our environment that has
allowed us to design cities and
pieces and pieces of art and pieces of
architecture and all these
different things that we've
created has all come from
that same desire, that desire
to continually improve. But if,
if the human body,
if we transcend it with some sort of an
artificial creation and we've become far
more enlightened, intelligent, the,
the ultimate question will be why?
Well, I would say the ultimate
question for me would be who are we?
Yeah. What are we, what you're, yeah.
Or what, because you know, when,
when I'm listening to you talk
about this and I'm like, Huh,
there's a part of me that's like,
no, like, let's not do that.
And then there's this other
part of me that's like, yeah,
that desire to create and
that desire to move forward.
And the evolutionary impulse
in us all is so strong.
And that's what makes us so beautiful.
And so when I have really touch into
the mystery of it all and the beauty and
the wonder and what you're
talking about with the art,
to me it's like not such a question
of trying to get out of this anymore.
It's more like a question of how can we
use these technologies and the things
that we are learning through science
and the natural laws of things.
Because honestly, if we start to
violate much more of our natural laws,
our oceans are going to rebel and like
our earth is going to become unstable.
And we're seeing some of that.
So we do have to balance the biological
component with the evolutionary impulse.
And one thing that comes to my mind is
a philosopher Ken Wilber talks about
transcend include a lot.
So what if, you know,
part of what we're doing is learning how
to transcend some of our limitations as
human beings. And at the same time
include some of those limitations, um,
that keeps us grounded. Um, I think
that's really important as well.
Transcend and include.
Yeah.
I just wonder what would happen if we
eliminated all of our biological urges and
would things just completely stop?
Why would anybody create art if we
don't want to impress other folks? Well,
if I think of, we have
a choice, maybe some,
some individuals would choose to do to
eliminate those things and maybe some
would choose not to. Right? Yeah. Well,
if there's like a huge diversity and
it's not just one thing that we become,
what if it's like many things and people
just kind of decided to go off and
reprogram their consciousness
and various ways why?
I've always been fascinated by this idea
of constant improvement and it's sort
of what fuels modern corporations.
This idea of constant growth
is it fuels human beings.
Like no one is happy with where they are.
They want a bigger house,
they want a better car. They want,
you know, if they're an artist,
they want to create their latest,
greatest masterpiece.
They don't want to sit on their laurels.
They want to consistently,
constantly improve. Where's the iPhone
six I'm still waiting. I'm waiting.
I'm like, yeah, we have this consistent,
constant need for improvement.
And that is essentially designed in
into the evolutionary process itself.
Like that's what led single
celled organisms to divide,
become multi-celled organisms to
get out of the ocean, to seek land,
to seek shelter, to seek
improvements in, you know,
altering its environment in order to
protect itself from predators. It's,
which led us to the 21st
century to where we are today.
Having this conversation that somehow,
I don't know if you understand it,
but I don't understand how my voice is
being processed down into ones and zeros
and pump through the sky and people are
getting it on their phone right now is
they're driving in their car. This is
madness. This is a mad, mad, mad world.
And what is the, what's the
urge behind all of it? Well,
it's this biological need for innovation,
this biological need for
constant improvement and it's,
it's designed in the evolutionary
process itself. I mean,
it's a part of the evolutionary process.
I mean, why? Why do animals evolve?
Why don't they just say fuck it? If these
fish keep grabbing us, let's just, uh,
let's just stay the same
color and go extinct.
No bugs you like start looking like,
have you seen caterpillars that like
look like predators they have did develop
eyes on their backs so that they can
look scary so that less animals eat them?
Or at least they have gotten to that
point where that design, I mean,
I don't know how you can ever really,
truly,
completely explain some
of these butterflies that
have these elaborate images
that have sort of throughout,
I mean,
how many hundreds of thousands or
millions of years of evolution, but it's,
it's incredibly fascinating that they've
developed this need to figure out how
to trick animals so that they can
continue to breed. They've improved,
they've innovative and that's that.
If you could really talk to a
butterfly and go listen to it,
you only live a week. Why
fucker? What do you care?
Like if you die or your relatives die,
what kind of a bullshit life is this?
You know, you live a week, you fly around,
people go, Ooh, look at the butterfly.
And then it's over. Like, let a
bunch of lizards eat you. Let's,
let's just get this over
with. Let's, you know,
come back as a better bug figure out how
to exist as a microbe inside the body
of the animals that are eating you and
then develop from its poop into some
magical plant that enlightens the
people that eat it or something.
But living as a butterfly is bullshit,
but they don't think that way.
There's just this, it's part of this
process is continue to innovate,
constantly push forward,
make things better.
If we stop being biological,
does everything just stopped?
Does everything just eh, and did you
know what, what is the conversation then?
What if you don't have a
motivation? If the, you,
you don't have an expiration date,
if you don't have
people's,
uh,
sexual choices to appeal to if you don't
have people's social choices to appeal
to.
If you don't want people to like you,
if you don't have any desire biologically,
what's the motivation?
Okay.
Well, I mean, obviously this is highly
speculative in a way. Yes. But, um,
hm.
Maybe I'd just throw in one piece. Sure.
Okay. Kind of bring it back down to the,
um, to the analog version of,
of intelligence, which is, uh,
these human bodies sitting here
having this conversation. Um,
if that's okay with you. Um, I,
I'd say there's another piece that's
really important in what you're saying.
There is the drive to
innovate and to transcend,
but then I think there's also a very
powerful force that moves in the other
direction and I would call it
compassion or care or love.
And it's that part of us that
wants to include everything.
Like Emily mentioned, transcending
and including, you know,
we can become better
and better and better,
but what good is it if everyone
else has left behind, you know,
what good is it if
we're, you know, living,
living the high life and
there are millions of people
who are struggling to feed
themselves, um, you know,
at some level when we get in touch with
the reality of that there's part of us,
if our hearts are open,
you know,
that really resonates with the pain of
that and wants to include and wants to
respond to that suffering
into that difficulty.
And I think that's part of the
reason life exists as well.
It's one of the primary reasons
is not just to transcend,
but it's also to care for and
to respond to the needs of,
because we realized
it's not just about us.
Like it's not just this experience
that's important. There are the,
all these others,
you know,
that are also having an experience and
they're not unlike me. You know, there,
and that's why compassion can can exist
because I realize like your experience
is not unlike my experience. There's a
way in which we have this common, um,
hardware wetware this common
sense of consciousness.
I assume this, you know,
calm, common hopes and fears,
desires. Um, and so in
that sense, you know,
I think compassion is a really powerful
force that also holds life together and
keeps it from fleeing apart into the,
into the ethers.
But the cynical objective amongst
us would look at that and say, well,
that's just a mechanism.
In order to keep society together to
allow this consistent innovation, you,
you need people to stay together in
order to get people to work together in
order to get the maximum amount of
productivity out of the human mind and
creativity. I mean, there's no, there's
only one way they have to love each other.
If they don't love each other, they're
not going to build shit. They're not,
they're going to go live like Ted
Kaczynski and hide up in the woods and a
little shack and try to stay away
from each other as much as possible.
Part of the reason why we do so
well is because we have compassion.
So it could certainly be considered an
evolutionary device to ensure innovation
and constant growth. And it has, I mean,
every society that has done well has been
a society that cherished its members.
If you don't give a
fuck about your members,
you get a North Korea type situation where
there's no innovation. The, the, the,
the country stagnant. Everyone lives
in fear. The lights are off at night.
And that's a worst case
scenario for a modern culture.
And that model that is based
almost entirely on the,
those same ideas that like the,
the lack of compassion for
your fellow beings exhibited.
Like if you looked at the
one thing or you ask me,
what's the one thing that troubles you
most about a brutal dictatorship like
North Korea,
while the poor people that live there,
the poor people that are suffering,
that lived there,
our compassion as a part of what makes
us, it's a, it's a, it's a component,
a critical component,
which makes us successful.
Yeah. And I think, you know, you can
look at it from that perspective,
but I think there's other
ways to look at it. Um,
which has that compassion in and
of itself as a good, you know,
that there's something inherent in the
experience of compassion of the open
heart that's responding to suffering,
which is in itself good.
And that hum,
you know,
when you experience and touch into
that space which completely dissolves
cynicism, um, in, in the
moment of it. Um, there is, uh,
there is this feeling of
this is this is right.
Like this is right to respond to the
difficulty of other beings because on some
fundamental level we aren't separate from
each other and in some fundamental way,
the level of the, of the
universe itself, you know,
everything arose out of this
momentary big bang, right?
That's our current story about it.
Like, okay, what the fuck was that?
Where did that w w what was that?
That it all came from this nothing,
this infinitely small point
in space actually, you know,
the Big Bang isn't something
that happened in the past.
It's something that is happening
right now. It's something that the,
that which was prior to the universe is
still here and that is also our nature
and that nature is naturally
compassionate. It naturally responds.
It naturally includes everything.
So I think there's something in us
that also wants to reunite with our own
deepest heart and our own deepest mind,
but does it right
really? Because if that's
the case, and how do you,
how do you factor in predators?
How do you factor in the,
the,
the constant competition in the
wild that exists everywhere.
Compassion really only exists when there's
safety. So the only time that exists,
when would you know, when you worry
about your own existence constantly,
it's like this rabid
sort of primal struggle.
What all that is put to rest and you
build up walls and you have a fire and you
can hold each other and
everyone's together and fine.
Then there's the the room
and need for compassion.
But with the Eagle and the fish,
there's no compassion.
I think you're speaking to our habitual
patterns that get ingrained in us as we
grow up. And with the Buddhist
training that I've been through,
it really does teach us how to start
to deconstruct some of that training.
I mean,
compassion naturally arises in a moment's
notice without there being this strong
sense of like contraction around
our small sense of self. You know,
when your child reaches for the stove,
you're going to try to jerk it back
because you don't want it to burn itself.
Right? That's a level of
compassion does naturally arising
well. That's, that's also being,
uh, you're in a mentor role.
You're teaching this human being about
things and it doesn't understand yet.
Yeah.
I would think of more of compassion as
someone you have no biological connection
to at all and you see them
in need of help and you help.
And there's something that's
inherently satisfying about that. Um,
when you do help someone,
it's very strange.
Like me and my friend Todd were driving,
we were in North Carolina and we were
driving down the road and we saw this car.
It had like, um, it's ha hazards on,
but they were like really, really damn.
And I was on the side of the
road. And, uh, as we pass the car,
maybe a couple hundred yards later,
we saw a guy lying on his back and we
were like, oh shit, something happened.
So we stopped the car, we got out, we
helped. The guy would called nine one one.
We got the guy up, he had severe
asthma, his car ran out of gas and he,
he had an asthmatic attack and fell and,
and we spent a bunch of time
with this guy and the cops. And,
and after it was over, we have this like
feeling the guy was safe. The guy was,
you know, the guide him in
the hospital, in an ambulance.
They took him to the hospital. They
did, the whole thing was resolved.
And we had this like elation,
this like light feeling happiness
that we did something. Yeah,
we were tired and we just flown in and
we would rather just go to our hotel,
but instead we spend an hour
or so and we felt way better.
You know,
it's like this feeling of elevation
you've helped your fellow being right.
So it's naturally programmed.
Dennis.
And so therefore we can
continue to cultivate that.
And so it's more of a consistent state
that's present. That's
what I've learned. Yeah.
That's where the cynic would say that the
whole reason for that is so that these
humans can breed and make
more humans to figure,
figured out a made way to make a better
electric car who figured out a way to
make like a wormhole.
It also reminds me of science
in the mirror neurons to,
cause we're learning that,
you know,
we're mirroring each other and what
you're doing is effecting me and what I'm
doing is affecting you and it's rewiring
our brains as we're talking. So, yeah.
So I mean,
in that sense like we really are so
connected that we don't even realize how
connected we are. So in a sense, yeah,
it is one of the most important things
you did connect. Connection
is undeniable. And it's, uh,
it's fascinating when you see people
change the people that they hang around
with. Yeah. And they all of
a sudden improve or regress.
And that's a, that's a consistent
pattern with human beings.
You find a really good group of friends
are super healthy and like to do a lot
of exciting,
fun things and they're compassionate to
each other and you start mimicking that
behavior or at least mirroring
that behavior, right?
Or when you're around people
that are just complete massive.
So we don't have to be ruled
by her biological desires.
So when you're saying like greed and
hatred and competition and all that,
then I mean maybe that is where we are
at a certain point in some of us are and
with evolutionary drive to continue to
create an open and really deepen into
what some of the wisdom traditions
have been talking about, then you know,
it's possible to like, I dunno,
evolve ourselves as we're,
as we're even talking here.
Yeah.
But Mike,
my question remains like when you
remove all of these biological urges,
what is the purpose of this thing?
Because it doesn't,
this doesn't seem to me that there would
be any reason to go on if you removed
everything biologic.
That's just, yeah, that's just something,
I mean, you can think like that,
but what would be the purpose we do?
I think it's hard to know.
I mean this is my point of view is like,
it's hard to know because we don't know
what it would be like, right. To be that,
to be whatever that is. Yeah. Mine's
go and try to construct it all.
So it's sort of like,
if we can only imagine what it
would be like not to be like we are,
but it's hard to imagine what it would
be like to be something that has yet not
yet emerged.
So maybe maybe we could have a followup
interview and we've all attained
superintelligence and we can be
no need for podcasts. Well we can,
we can get together in the, uh, the
instantaneous MindMeld which is, you know,
intelligence and riff on that.
That
to me seems more likely than any
of those other scenarios. I, I,
I wonder like what the next step is.
I've stopped many times and I've spent
like entire days thinking about a
thousand years from today to a
thousand years from now. Like, what is,
what is the difference and what,
what is the difference going to be
and how radical is it going to be?
How radical was the shift?
And I really have a feeling that it's
going to have nothing to do with the body
and all to do with the mind.
And I think that this idea of
transcending the, the human body,
and I have a feeling they're going to
figure out some way that the human mind
can access other states,
dimensions,
levels of consciousness that literally
the human body will be irrelevant.
Well, it already can. Oh yeah. We,
we already can access all kinds of crazy
stuff for some of the trainings that
I've learned in meditation or
psychedelics opened that up. Yeah,
yeah, exactly right. But what's going
on there? What is that? Do we know?
What is that?
Is that,
are you opening up the flood gates for
human neuro transmitters and the body's
ability to process them get skewed and
you, it presents you with all sorts of,
you know, delusional beliefs
and crazy visions because your,
your visual cortex can't process
all these chemicals correctly.
So you have this wild,
fantastic ride,
gives you the sense of euphoria and
this elated sense of being disillusioned
with it. Huh? No, not at all. No. Just
completely offering the devil's advocate.
Yeah, yeah. No, I, I appreciate that.
I mean I think that point of view is
coming at it from the biological physical
perspective, but then there's all said
that perspective of consciousness itself,
you know,
of the experiential aspect of it,
which is I think also a
part of the challenge of our
moment in time I think is,
is starting to recognize that both of
these perspectives are valid, that the,
the perspective of consciousness
of experience is also valid.
So from the perspective of
consciousness, you know, it,
those altered states of experience reveal
something valid. Now whether or not,
you know, we can from that point of
view, describe the biology of it.
I think it's clear we can't,
and so it's useful to have a description
of like this is what's happening in the
brain,
these areas or d,
Afrin shading and then these areas
are lighting up and all of that stuff.
But that's not who we,
that's not all of who we are.
We're not just brains because you know,
we're having thoughts about brains and
the only way brains exists is through
our, through our internal
representations of brains and in,
in terms of human consciousness.
So I think, you know,
that'd be the other perspective is like
consciousness itself is also a valid
perspective on this. And from
that point of view, you know,
those moments of altered
experience of like compassion,
like you described when you realized
you helped the person in Asheville, um,
and were there for him or you know,
when your child's born or when you take
a hallucinogenic a medicine with the
intention of learning more
about your old, you know, your,
your deepest nature or something about
yourself or going on a meditation retreat
and exploring your
experience moment by moment.
I think those things reveal very
important truths that are at the level of
consciousness itself that,
you know,
you can't convince a skeptic
or cynic that they're true,
but you can give them the
instructions and say, hey,
run this program and see
what happens. Um, and, and,
and if you do it with a certain kind
of intention, then you know, it,
it changes your life.
It changes your perspective,
it changes your sense of who you are,
you know, and what this is all about.
And I appreciate that you're pointing
out, you know, the, the one side of it,
which is that, you know, yeah,
this is a, this is a limited trip.
Like we don't, we don't really know
what the hell is happening here.
We don't know how he got into this body.
At least I don't remember
how I got into this body.
I don't know why it's happening. Right.
Um, and then like, we're gonna die,
you know, at some point, and we don't
know when. That's the other thing.
We know we're going to die, but we
don't know when. We don't know how, um,
we don't know how long for now.
And so there is a certain,
certain kind of like in your face
shock about that, that I think we're
constantly coping with as human beings.
You know, we're crying constantly and
compassion can be a way to cope with that.
You know and love,
like there's a term that the,
this Tibetan master used who came to
the America and the 70s named chuck him
trunk,
but,
and he said there's compassion and
then there's idiot compassion and idiot
compassion is when you are trying to
respond to suffering because you can't
handle it because you don't,
you can't actually deal with it.
So you try to like make it go away or you
try to Oh poor you, poor you, you know,
that kind of compassion.
So compassion can just as easily be a way
to cope with the shocking reality that
we don't know what's even
going to happen next,
let alone like what's going to
happen in 5,200 years from now.
Um,
does that make sense?
Sort of.
I always felt like compassion was just
the way that we kept together the,
we kept our love for each other and bonds
and that feeling other people's pain
is a way to ensure that we
minimize that as much as possible.
And that it's just sort of a
part of the biological process,
especially the biological process of
transcending the simple monkey mind.
And moving into some new state,
the the ability to understand each other,
communicate, express
information and, and, and,
and also to be able to conceptualize
very bizarre ideas that human beings have
kind of based their entire society on.
We based our society on
bizarre things like laws,
regulations, money, the bandwidth,
you know,
there's a weird concepts that we have had
to factor in to our view of the world,
the environment, our, our,
our interaction with that environment
or effect on that environment.
How much can we mitigate that?
How much is just a necessary
evil to maintain our,
our wonderful existence with
air conditioning and you
know, high speed Internet.
I mean, what, what are
those thoughts were,
where are those things going and how
much of those are connected to, again,
the same thing.
This constant need to stay together,
help each other innovate,
how each other move forward,
press forward and continue to grow.
And is something like Buddhism or
transcendental meditation or anything,
are these just sort of like ways
to get through this and in a,
in a relatively sane way, are these
essentially man created technologies,
human created technologies to
mitigate the natural world?
I mean, in a way they clearly
are. I mean, cause humans, yeah.
I'm sat under trees,
you know,
in India 2,500 years ago of thousands of
years ago and explored their own minds
and did come up with various,
you know, programs for how to,
how to work with experience.
Isn't that fascinating that someone a
long time ago was like looking around
people hacking each other to death
with swords and he was like, you know,
there's gotta be a way around some
of this shit, you know, like what is,
what's going on here?
Why is everybody,
why is every launch in arrows
over the top of those walls?
Like what the fuck are we
doing and why in India,
what the hell is going
on in India? Yeah. Know,
India's been the birthplace of alive
developments in consciousness and not
coincidentally
worships cows who not coincidentally make
cow shit from double Angela at animals
that siliciden mushrooms grow on
and completely connected for sure.
Without a doubt. And Soma, you know, the,
the ancient vedic traditions and all
these ancient Hindu texts that speak of
these psychedelic drugs, we don't
even know what the hell they were.
These important psychedelic aspects of
their culture that are completely lost.
Like no one knows what Soma is.
It means it's a huge part of their
ancient religious tradition and you know,
whatever it is is like
completely up for debate.
Some feel it's a common story drug with,
you know,
the Amanita miscarry and silicide bin
and all sorts of different things,
but no one knows just all guesswork,
but that's gotta be a part of it. Right.
Someone ate some mushrooms and said,
those cows are awesome. We need to keep
those guys around. Don't eat the cows.
Eat this. Oh yeah, I don't need the
cows like this came from the cows. Yes.
You know,
like what a trip.
I'm just starving people letting cows
go because the cows make shit that
from scrolling.
Yeah man.
I think it's crazy too that people
figured out how to pay attention and use
their body in a way to produce some of
those effects and dodgy honestly know to
be able to experience that even
without mushrooms, you know,
to be able to get into this kind of
states of consciousness and even to
stabilize them, you know, as
a, as a kind of of existence.
Well
Delaney masters people that are
really good at, and Delaney,
I have a friend who teaches it and he
says that he can reach these complete
psychedelic states where he's interacting
with beings that may or may not be
there that he can visually
recognize in front of him.
Like he can see it as if he's tripping.
And I'm like, well, how do you,
how are you getting there?
It's just years and years and years
of mindfulness in this very specific
right concentration,
you know,
is the always tied to and
every contemplative tradition,
these sort of psychedelic
or psychic experiences,
it's like the ability to focus and to,
to be able to absorb consciousness in
one thing seems to be the gateway and to
which, you know, all of those other
weird, yeah, experiences can arise,
but you're told to not pay attention.
Those experiences that that's like you're
missing the point if you're trying to
seek out these hallucinations,
Simpson traditions.
A lot of Buddhist traditions
do sort of suggest dunk,
not getting sidetracked by them,
but they inform us and change the way
that we can relate to things that they are
important and goal,
that they can definitely do a
lot of good work, you know, and,
and a lot of weird shit. Oh yeah. I mean
sorcery like in Tibet, you know? Yeah.
There's like all these people like out
there like casting weird stuff at each
other. And you know, I don't,
I haven't been to Tibet,
so I don't know how much of it is like
you can just see weird stuff happening
and how much of it is their mythology,
but all the same,
like there's enough weird stories coming
out of places of people that have been
sitting in caves for millennia
exploring their own consciousness.
So we're already uploading. I mean,
we've been, I guess, uploading,
at least on some level.
Well,
the artwork itself as
representative of these experiences,
if you look at to baton artwork, it's so
trippy. It's mindblowing. So psychedelic.
Oh yeah. Oh yeah. We did it. A
meditation a couple of weekends ago,
and one of the guided meditations was
to imagine a lotus flower in your heart
that had a thousand petals and each
petal with shooting off a beam of clear
light that connected with another
pedal and another being's heart.
And that sort of spread it out infinitely.
But it also went in both directions,
like in terms of the atomic and quantum
level and the universes within Adams.
And it went outward in all
directions. And I'm like, wow,
okay these these dudes were,
you know,
cause they mostly were dudes
that were able to do this.
These dudes were like exploring the
furthest reaches of, of the inner,
you know,
Cosmos.
What do you mean by there were mostly
dudes that were able to do this? Well,
I mean the cultures of Tibet
and most of these places,
you know there were nuns and there
were women doing the practices,
but I don't think they had as much
opportunity to do them because of the,
you know,
the Organization of their cultures.
But there's not a biological limitations
and achieving these experiences. No.
Actually the Tibetans say
women have an easier time at,
at these practices for seven.
Imagine that
because testosterone is so controlling
and limiting in that sense.
Like there's so much ego bound
to testosterone and also the,
the mortality of testosterone,
like being the one that
survives and all that,
it is inexorably sort of connected to
the, the, the sex hormone over the mail.
I would imagine that that
would be more limiting.
Emily has a better meditator than I am.
I practice twice as hard and
experience half the results.
Do you guys ever go in a sensory
deprivation tanks? I have not done that.
I haven't done that yet. How
dare both of you, I know,
I know it's such a confusing thing to
me because I've been such an advocate on
the sensory deprivation tank and I
talked to so many people that are into
meditation and like how do you not use
the one tool that is essentially like
designed for the best meditation
possible? Well retreats, you know, we,
we've both done a lot of months of
intensive retreat and it's kind of like
sensory deprivation. I mean you don't
talk, you don't, um, you know, you,
you eat what's in front of
you. You, you're sitting in
silence most of the time.
It like, it really does limit the
sensory input. Um, and you know,
I've been in states of consciousness
where all sensory input sort of disappears
for awhile.
So I feel like I've had that experience
of how could you say that though if you
haven't done it, if you haven't
done the actual tank itself? Oh,
I don't know how it compares exactly,
but I know what it's like to experience
a lack of sensory input. Right.
Until you sign a certain level
and a certain level that you know,
there's no sense of visual sight sound.
It's actually probably deeper because
there's no sense of the body at all in
those states. It's completely
formless, um, deeper than what?
Deeper than if you're laying in a tank
and you still have an experience of the
senses of your body.
Like if you can still feel your body,
can you feel your body in
a sensory denomination? No,
that's the whole point. Okay,
so it's probably similar. More
intense. This is why I've done both.
And the sensory deprivation tank,
you're weightless, we'll have to do it.
You're floating in water. That's the
same, the temperatures of your skin.
So you don't recognize where
the water ends and the, your,
your body completely ceases to
send information to you. Yeah.
And if you guys are
already good at meditating,
meditating in a tank would be like
turbo charged probably, right?
100% guaranteed.
I can't believe you haven't done it,
but why don't you have a sponsor yet
for for uh, I sent in my basement.
I have a tank in my basement.
I go in that soccer all the time.
You need a new advertiser here.
I think I could sort of help my frank
crash who owns a, the float lab in Venice,
but I don't do it for
financial compensation.
I just do it because I want people
to know about it. But I would, I do,
I retweet people's tanks all the time that
I have no affiliation with whatsoever.
Just cause I think it's an,
it's a massively important tool that is
somehow or another slipped through the
fingers of, of our, our,
our consciousness. I don't,
I don't get how people haven't grabbed
a hold of that and ran with it.
I read a study one time
that says a lot of people,
once they have some sort of opening,
we could call
it mystical experience, for lack
of a better word right now, um,
that a lot of people don't want to have
him again after they've had it the first
time. Something about the opening
kind of freaks people out. Um,
but I'm just saying, yeah, I mean
that and it can be scary for people.
So it seems like the
expansion of consciousness is
something that is naturally
in us as well.
And so thinking about the technology where
we started this conversation a little
bit,
it's like there is this impulse to
explore and to like expand and upload into
different states and realms of being.
But that fear of expansion,
that's just, that's just the ego,
that's all that is.
That's just your body trying to
reclaim like some sort of walls.
What's,
let's put boundaries on this sucker so
we can clearly defined it where you know,
when you have a psychedelic experience,
one of the things that's the most talked
about aspect of it is the boundary
dissolving aspect of it.
That the boundaries all dissolve.
And like I remember one of
the first times that I did a,
a really potent psychedelic
was five Meo DMT.
And the overwhelming message from it was
that there's no up and there's no down
and that you're just a part of the,
the infinite.
And that feeling is very
like saying it like this is,
it sounds like just a bunch of noise
coming out of your mouth that sort of
vaguely represents what
this concept would be.
But experiencing it in a psychedelic
state was so overwhelmingly educational.
And so,
um,
it was so boundary defining like whatever
I had thought of as a boundary in the
past was now like,
oh,
that was just this and
this is just that and what,
what you really are is one thing that is
holding all these other things that are
all a part of this huge thing.
And this huge thing is you're in it.
You're not separate.
I'm not separate from you.
You and I are these containers
that are inside of this.
There's air and there's, there's
always something there. There's no,
there's no nothing. It doesn't
exist. There's no nothing,
there's no nothing anywhere.
Even nothing is something.
Yeah, no. Shinzen young, one
of our favorite teachers,
he says emptiness is not a thing.
It's a pure doing.
Which is sort of another way of saying,
I think what you're pointing to,
that everything is just happening
as it is. And there's no, um,
in a sense there's no thing that
even goes beyond all of that.
It's just this, you know, it's just
this happening that's happening.
Universe also is like a soup.
It's not like a,
you're not throwing a ball through
the air and someone's catching it.
It's not hitting anything. It's not a
vacuum. Like the whole thing is just,
it's filled with something.
It's all connected. Like you,
you and I aren't really separate from
each other. We're just not touching skin,
but we're touching something that's
touching us. It's in that, you know,
we're all feeling that, boy, that
sounds hippy. Ooh, that's Hippie Shit.
But it's, but it's also true. Yeah.
In some way it's also true.
And that these, these ideas,
whether it's meditation or yoga or
psychedelics or these ideas of mindfulness
are in a lot of ways an attempt
to escape this monkey realm,
to escape this biological realm that
we find ourselves in, to try to,
if not escape it,
rather, um, to manage it.
Transform it. Yes. I would say
transform it to what though?
I don't have a good answer to what kind
of looping back around where we started
this conversation to what
right. Isn't that like building
a house and you don't have plans?
Like what are you doing?
I'm just putting shingles on this thing
and it's going to hopefully be something
I think, I think, uh, having,
I mean, I think there,
there we each have to answer
that question too. What I mean,
and that's a very personal thing.
And that way you think, I mean,
I think it's personal in one way, but
it's also collective in another way. Um,
because we, you know, we,
we influence each other and
we get attracted to things
that are connected with
what's important to us. Um, but
you know, to me, to what, you know,
I think what's beautiful is, you know, to,
to move toward deep percents of wisdom to,
to move toward being able to live
in harmony with that realization of
interconnectivity of deep,
of that after kind of profound
interconnectivity that you're describing,
you know,
that literally that at some level
isn't a separation between us.
You know, w how does that then inform how
I live? How does that change how I live?
Do I sort of say,
oh,
well what's the fucking point and
just give up or do I, you know,
take that experience and
begin to dismantle habits and,
and ideas and beliefs that are opposed
to that experience and actually begin to
live more in harmony to,
you know,
in the kind of language of contemplative
training to embody that realization,
to make it your own, um, you know,
end to end to make your life and
expression of that an expression of that
interconnectivity and compassionate and,
um,
deep care and love for each
other and including, you know,
cutting through all the bullshit and
including calling out the delusion,
you know, including, you know,
pimp smacking the bullshit,
which is I think a big part of,
you know, what I see you doing here
and have it just say, leaving room
for the what to change. You know,
that's not like a fixed thing that
we're going to transform into this fixed
thing. We're going to continue
to, to change and to evolve.
And so that's beautiful to me,
Jen. Certainly beautiful from a
biological standpoint. I mean I'm,
I'm not a cynic in that I don't love life
and I don't love humans cause I, I, I,
I enjoy this experience incredibly. I
thought, I think it's an amazing time.
I think being a person is
great. I love it. I love people.
I love all fun things
you could do as a person.
But what I'm trying to get to,
when we were talking,
transhumanism and this,
I'm escaping the boundaries of biology.
There's a guy that we talked about in
this podcast before they got bitten by a
shark.
So Australian cat,
he lost his arm and his leg
and they replaced it with
this carbon fiber creation
and he's moving around.
He's standing there,
no limp guy walks around normal
has his hand that, you know,
it's kind of crude, but it does move and
it can pick things up. And I'm like, wow,
this is quite fascinating. Like
they said to this guy, hey,
I know you got your arm and leg put
off by shark, but lucky for you,
this is 2014 and we have some incredible
innovation that we've created that's
going to allow you to have this leg that
moves very much like a regular leg and
you're going to have a hand that can do
a lot of things that a regular hand can
do. So that's better than not having
that arm and leg and yes, and guess what?
It's going to get better.
Five years from now.
We'll have a better arm and a better leg
and you're going to enjoy this. Well,
if as time goes on,
the other parts of his body start
failing like a, you know what man?
There's problem because you
have this artificial right leg.
Your left knee is gone.
So we're going to replace your left
leg too with this artificial leg.
So this way you'll have two
artificial legs and they're,
but they're going to work
great. Okay, great. Okay,
listen man, your heart is going.
Uh,
but good news.
We have an artificial heart and we're
going to take this artificial and a
hundred years from now,
this guy is just a brain
in this carbon fiber body.
And he's looking at his eyes.
He's looking through these artificially
created eyes and they say, listen,
everything works great except the
cells of your brain are reproducing
irregularly and you're going
to develop Parkinson's.
But we have figured out a way to download
your consciousness into an artificial
brain.
So we'll just download your consciousness
into this art in the well what's left
of you? You don't, there's nothing.
There's no biology anymore and well
what's there then when you sit there like
they turn that switch on and your,
you know,
2.0 what,
what goes on there?
Well, from a, from a Buddhist perspective,
what's there is your, is your Karma.
What's there is the pattern that was
you leading up to that point. You know,
the information that made you up and
that has continued to move into this new
sub straight. Um, and that
pattern has a momentum to it.
It has, uh, a history. It has memories,
has beliefs. It has, you know, it
has various things. It doesn't,
it's not a complete discontinuity. Um,
the substrates changed. But the, uh,
you know, the pattern has
continued in some sense, right?
Maybe, but how much of that pattern
is based on biological need?
How much of that pattern is based on
this cultural conditioning and the,
the, just the patterns of behavior
that you've adopted along the way
and your life and the,
the environment in which you grew up in.
How much of that goes away when you have
a brain that's made out of fibers that
are constructed out of silicon and,
or whatever?
Depends on how it's constructed.
This reminds me of them.
I don't know if you've had the experience
in some of my teachers talk about this
as an example. A lot is, um, you know,
looking in the mirror now and you,
you kind of get surprised that,
that you've aged,
but there's something in you
that you don't feel as aged.
Do you ever have that experience? I do.
In what way? It's just like, you know,
you just,
there's part of you that has an
age and then at the same time,
if you look in the mirror, you can tell
that you've aged. Does that make sense?
There's a piece of us, right?
That's like, I don't know,
I still feel like nothing's changed
inside, inside your vehicle, but my feet,
but then I look in the mirror and I'm
like, oh my gosh. Yeah. Like I gotta,
I gotta have my time is taken even though
I'm young, you know? But I, I get that.
So there's this like
paradox kind of at play.
So when we're talking about like what
if we do upload or what is it that is
still there? Like I wonder if
some of that will still be there,
that feeling of nothing's changed.
And then there is this change
that happens when we age and
well, if we'd stop aging, I mean if the,
if it completely ends or
if it's a temporary aging,
we just got to go and get
repainted, you know? I mean,
if your car gets a Patina from,
you know,
rocks and chips on the road and stop,
all you have to do is bring to the body
shop and the old cars that look awesome.
You know, we can't do that
with a human being. But if
we can, if there's, you know,
there's companies that specialize in
replacing every single part of an old car
and creating you a new version of an old
car that that is ultimately incredibly
possible for a human being. I think
that's possible. That's crazy though.
You know, and there is this part of
us that wants to live forever. I mean,
the holy grail, like some of these
myths that existed for a long time. So
everybody wants to sleep, but
nobody wants to die. Yeah.
It's quite fascinating. Everybody's more
than happy to shut off for eight hours.
Like, Oh yeah, here we go. Nothing
I find bizarre. It's like,
I find it bizarre now is,
I mean a lot of the fear of death seems
to be connected to a fear of the unknown
of what would happen after death. Like,
am I just going to disappear? You know,
what's going to happen?
Um,
and not knowing that is part of,
I think of the terror,
the feeling of not knowing
what's going to happen.
And what I find interesting is, you
know, and we were just talking to her,
one of our zen teachers who, who teach
us here in Santa Monica, she pointed out,
you know, in every moment we actually
don't know what's coming next. You know,
that not knowing it, it's something
we're constantly having to deal with.
The terror of not
knowing, uh, or you know,
as her zen teacher called it
the don't know mind, you know?
And so I find it interesting to kind of
reflect on what it's like to rest in the
not knowing to rest in that,
that sense of not knowing
what's gonna come next.
Because in that moment,
every next moment is both a death of
this moment and the rebirth of something
new. There's something new coming online
and there's something disappearing.
And in that sense,
I think if we become comfortable and
familiar with that process of moment by
moment, birth and death, then
you know, whatever happens,
whether my consciousness gets
uploaded to the cloud or I die,
there's some sense of there's some part
of me which is fundamentally okay with
that death process,
that the constant dying.
And that was the thing I always thought
was funky about the attempt to escape
death.
Because actually in order to escape death,
we're going to have to go through so
many deaths of who we think we are.
You know, like you're
saying, you know, to, to,
to transplant your consciousness into a
silicon brain like some part of you dies
in that. And so we're trying to escape
death by running into it headlong.
Well also what if death is
merely a transitionary phase?
What if you are,
you live in this existence,
but when you die you will
enter into a new existence.
And this is what many ancient religions
have speculated on throughout the
beginning of time. I mean,
since the beginning of time,
everyone thinks that there's some sort of,
I mean,
whether it's wishful thinking or
whatever it is, it might be real.
Just like consciousness is a very
bizarre thing to try to define,
but it is certainly a real thing.
You know,
if you tried to put consciousness
in a lab and say like, what is it?
What is it that causes creativity?
What is it that would define love in some
sort of a chemical process? No. Well,
good luck with that. You know? Good luck
with trying to figure out why. What that,
what that warm feeling is when you
see your friend at the airport,
no time magazine cover that
says that you couldn't,
they couldn't find the God particle.
Do you remember that? Yeah.
In the brain they can't find it.
Yeah.
Well, what is it? You
know, what, what, what is,
there's so many different
aspects to what is life? What,
what defines this existence for the
person who experiences at themselves and
does that transition to something
else at the moment of death?
And is that why the brain,
it produces all these
indigenous psychedelic
chemicals that give you when you
take them, give you this elated
sense of being, give you this,
this sense of relieving of anxiety and
this sense of connection to everything
and everything. Every one that
exists, like what? Why do those exist?
Like why are those chemicals in the
mind and why are those chemicals,
why they released at the moment of death,
why they release it?
The moment of extreme stress when
your body's worried it's going to die.
Why those released during the dream state?
Like what?
What is that and would we be trapping
whatever consciousness we have now in this
artificial creation.
If you can download consciousness
into some artificial creation,
is that a hellish existence for that
consciousness because it's no longer able
to transition to the next phase of being
and would you be able to transition to
that next phase phase of being as a
biological entity and then realize like,
oh my God,
what did I do with my consciousness?
I left it back there in that fucking robot
and who and who would be conscious of
that? If there was no conscious.
Yeah. Well what is it? What you know,
what is that thing? What is the life, what
is the life that gets that transitions.
The life expires, the, the light
goes out and you pass over.
But yet this robot wakes up and
it's you and it has no lifespan.
You know, it has no whatever
it, no sexual urges.
No need for community is just this thing
that has all of your memories. Yeah.
I hope you don't design the future Ai.
Well we have real problems.
If we design it to mimic and
replicate biological life,
we have real problems there.
We'd have real problems if we didn't too.
That's true as well. Will the biological
us would. Yeah. Cause we would, you know,
that's where the terminator comes to.
It has no need for us.
What's it's why everything that we are
as far as what the way our society is
structured as far as the, our senses
of fairness and love and compassion.
They're all based on
biological urges and needs.
The need for community is a strong
urge to keep us all together.
So we stay alive longer. I
mean, all of these things are,
they're a part of being a biological
entity. And when we no longer are,
why would we engineer all of those
biological urges and thoughts and concepts
into this carbon fiber creation?
I've heard the argument, and I think
this is interesting too though,
that you know,
the need for community goes back to the
very earliest moments of the universe.
You know, that in some sense, you know,
when Adams, uh, when Adam has emerged,
they emerged in collectives,
you know,
that they didn't just
emerge as a single atom,
that they're always wins
when a single thing emerges.
It emerges also with a collective, you
know, in that sense, you know, the,
the sense of community is hardwired
maybe into the universe itself,
but isn't also the sense of competition
then because all biological life is this
wild race of things, eating
things, letting vegetarians,
I mean,
the whole idea is as things grow and
these other things come along and eat them
as they grow and there's no way
around it, life eats life, you know,
and you can try to keep your biological
footprint as small as possible.
And do as little harm as possible,
but every step you take is killing life.
Every time you close your mouth, you're
killing bacteria. I mean, you're,
you're doing,
when you wash yourself,
you're killing living things
is a lot of weirdness to this,
this whole life that is tied to survival,
tied to birth death and the prolonging
of the species or the improvement of the
species as it tries to
prolong. Absolutely. I mean,
it's a paradox to,
yeah,
but that's isn't that part of what's
cool about being alive is that it's not
gonna last.
I mean that's,
that's the one of the big issues
with the transhumanist movement,
this idea of transcending the biological
limitations and living forever, but,
but then it sucks. It's like a movie
that's a hundred hours long. You know,
I don't want to see star
wars for a hundred hours.
I want to see star wars for two hours
because at the end of two hours,
it's awesome. Like that
was a great movie. Yay.
You walk outside and
you're in the sunlight.
You talk about how great that moment was
with your friends. Everybody's happy.
But if star wars is goes on for infinity,
it fucking sucks, you know, for, you know,
a hundred years later it's still going
warp speed and Chewbacca is like fucking
get me Outta here. This is terrible.
This movie sucks. You know why?
Because it's boring. I don't want
to see it for a hundred hours.
I want to see it for two.
Is that life itself,
I mean the, the question
I would ask is, you know,
is it true that there will be no
limitations if we transcend our biological
limitations or is it the case that
there'll be new limitations that we can't
fathom? You know, that
become again, and this,
this ties in with the question that
we've asked ourselves, you know, with,
with the,
the Buddhist practice like
is enlightenment and end
state or is it an ongoing
ever unfolding process? You
know, and I think if it,
if it is an unfolding
ever evolving process,
then that means there will always be,
as long as there's stuff,
there will always be limitations.
There always be something that's
not quite as perfect as it could be.
Um, or that you know, is not
quite it. And so in that sense,
I would guess that,
I mean this is my guess is not that we
would transcend limitations altogether,
but that will transcend certain ones
and then discover new ones and then the
whole process of creative tension.
We'll begin again at some new, you know,
level and we'll be like, oh shit. Like I,
I really don't appreciate the fact
that I can't have two experiences
simultaneously that I've done.
There's this one experience.
Even if I can move between
multiple realms really rapidly,
I still can only have this one moment
of experience, you know, then what I am.
That's just a guess.
Maybe one of the limitations. Well that's
fascinating. What do you bring that up?
Because that, that does open up a
different realm of possibilities.
If we can transcend the limitations of
biology and that includes experiencing
multiple things simultaneously or the
ability to experience multiple lives.
Like if we figure out a way to combine
our consciousness or whatever we call our
consciousness,
once we transcend biological life
and combined our minds so that we do
experience the lives of multiple people,
if not the entire human race
that's on the same track,
experience it all simultaneously and
that that this is beyond the realm of
biological understanding and maybe that's
where we evolve from this thing and
become something that's far
more complex and complicated
in less in less.
One aspect of that decides it doesn't
want to be merged into the hole and then
you get warring factions or
Warren fraction problems.
Much larger scale warring factions of
transhumanism is trying to pull each
other's batteries out and trying to pull
each other into each other's version of
utopia. Yeah, right. Oh,
that's another issue, right?
Like what if there's like a Mac
version and a windows version and a non
compatible,
everyone's trying to figure out what,
which one is going to be the Beta Max and
which one, you know Betamax was better,
but VHS survived and you've got to
pick the right team. That's right.
Yeah. There's different. Yeah,
because it's not like there's going to
be only one company that comes up with a
transhumanist solution.
Right,
right. This is reminding me of like
the fluidity of it perspectives.
As I've trained in practice,
it's like the mind,
it has the capacity to take on multiple,
multiple perspectives and how important
that actually is in the world today to
be able to take different points of view
and take multiple perspectives and and
not have the right way or that way.
So there's a lot of
possibilities. Yeah. The
you said also this fascinating
is this idea that we,
we can't even really
imagine what the potentials
are because the potentials,
we'll create new potentials that
were before that, unrecognizable. We,
we didn't,
we didn't see them coming.
Like if you went back in time a few
hundred years ago and tried to explain to
them the Internet, they'd be like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
If you went back before the printing press
and tried to explain the internet and
trying to access Google on your
phone with voice commands or Siri,
you know, Siri. Yeah.
Try to explain that to people that
live before printed type to be like,
what are you even yapping about?
They would never be able to wrap their
head around it much like we will never be
able to wrap our head around
the possibilities once we
transcend the biological
limitations.
The hive mind to me seems to be
the most likely the hivemind. Yeah.
The idea that we're going to somehow or
another experience and experience each
other, uh, on some very, very broad scale,
some very large scale.
And I think we're kind of doing that
with shit like Facebook and with Twitter
and with interaction on the Internet.
I think what we're doing is dipping
our toe in the ocean of connectivity.
Oh yeah. I like that phrase.
Yeah. That's really good. Yeah.
Because think that we're slowly but
surely devolve or I'm dissolving or
developing maybe that suit biological
of all right. But dissolving these,
um,
limitations of communication,
we're slowly but surely
expressing ourselves in,
in ways and interacting in
ways that didn't exist before.
And then when new things come along, like
are you aware of Oculus rift? Yeah, sure.
I've got the Dev kit two waiting for
me in, in North Carolina. I can't wait.
Dunkin has it.
My friend Duncan Trussell has it and he
just got back from experiencing porn in
uh, in virtual reality, first
person porn and he goes,
it is the craziest thing you've
ever experienced in your life.
Like you are this other person
having sex with someone.
You could look down at your body,
you can look at your feet and your
legs and you can experience like sexual
intercourse with somebody that you
don't feel it obviously, but he's like,
this is going to change the
entire world we live in.
And the new version of it is insanely
high definition. Right. And you know,
he keeps saying,
yeah,
you got to come over my house and
try out the fucking new rift. Man,
it's mind blowing.
He called me up the day he saw
it and he's like, he's like,
this is bigger than the Internet.
He goes,
this is bigger than anything that's
ever been invented by people. Yeah,
I've heard the same thing.
And I mean,
the thing I'm most excited
about is creating contemplative
training environments
in, in, in the rift. You know, what
would it be like to completely, you know,
like you said, immerse yourself
in a visual field, you know,
with nothing outside of it and be
able to, you know, in some sense, uh,
experience some of the same states
that psychedelics burnout bring on,
but you know, directly through a
technological interface. You know,
I'm one of my friends called
it techno deluxe. You know,
that the sense that the technology could
produce some of the states as well.
Well,
that's what Mckenna,
his belief was sure about DMT is that
he believed that if you could create a
world that mimics exactly the psychedelic
experience of dimethyl trip to mean
that he believed that in that state,
those same beings that you interface
with when you take the psychedelic drugs
would show up. He had this like field of
dreams type scenario. If you build it,
they'll come and that that would be
the best case scenario for psychedelic
intervention. It wasn't getting
a bunch of people to take drugs.
It's like put this on
virtual reality, this, yeah,
that one day the state will,
I mean the,
the virtual reality will
achieve the, the, the,
the type of possibilities to achieve
something like that. Yeah. And then,
and then the question becomes, you know,
and I think Mckenna said this, you know,
what, what worlds do we build?
You know, what virtual reality is,
do we build and what values do we
build into them and program into them?
You know, cause I don't think
that issue is going to go away.
We still have to ask this questions
and decide what we're building. Well,
again, that's the big, the
real mind. Fuck. It's, it's
not even essentially that, um,
you know, like we're going to
a different biological body,
but we might have a different reality
that is indistinguishable from this
reality that we can pick
up and put on a scale the,
the concept of virtual existence of some
sort of existence in a simulation as it
were.
You know,
the simulation is a weird word because
simulation implies that it's not real.
But if it has all the consequences and
all the feeling and textures and all the
interactions and interfaces that you're
the regular life does as far as tactile,
as far as heat sensitivity,
you all the different aspects of our life.
But we can recreate those. Exactly.
What is that? If it's not life,
I don't, I'm not. If it is
an experience and you're,
you're taking in every single aspect of
that experience exactly the same way you
would take in this life, what
is it? And if that's the case,
how do we know we're not
all the already in it?
How do we know that this isn't good and
indistinguishable artificial reality
that we have created and we're just
tapped into this sucker? I mean,
that's my presumption that
we're in an artificial reality.
I mean, I, I presume this is a virtual
reality simulation. Yeah. Why is that?
Because it,
because stuff's happening and
I don't know what's happening.
Okay.
What do you mean by that?
I mean, I guess we were watching
Nick Bostrom last night,
kind of lay out the argument for this,
you know,
the virtual reality simulation hypothesis.
Yeah. And he was basically saying,
you know, one possibility is in
we, we're in a virtual reality, uh,
an ancestral simulation.
And then the other possibility is that
no technology note know civilizations get
to the point technologically where they
can produce this kind of technology.
They all vanish. That's
one possibility. Um,
and then the third possibility was,
I'll see if I can remember it.
I don't understand that possibility.
So,
so basically saying
this is a real universe,
because know civilizations get so,
so there could be no civilization,
which gets to the point where
it develops that capacity,
that virtual reality technology.
But what,
how was that even an option?
No civilization does it make he
could say no civilization has,
oh yeah, no civilization has,
you know, so that there are so,
because he's assuming that if,
if someone does do it,
this is getting kind of
analytically geeky. But, um,
so it was this whole damn show,
right? Yeah, that's true. But he,
I think he's saying like, if, if, if,
if a hyper intelligent species can create
a virtual reality, they will, you know,
and they'll create many of them. Right.
And so it's Probabil probability wise,
it's much more likely that we're in a
simulation because of how many that could
be created.
You know,
you get some light emit an infinite
number of universes through a,
like a hyper in a next
generation computer.
So that was his argument for why
we're probably in a simulation.
Never say probably, uh, I, I would
agree in the sense that it's,
it's quite possible that if it is
possible to one day achieve this sort of
technological ability to create something
that's indistinguishable from this
reality.
If it is possible,
and I assume that it's
going to be possible if you
hear about things like this
new oculus rift and
compare it to the quill,
they used to have to dip into
ink to write things down.
That was the only way to
distribute information. Yeah,
it's possible that one day
we're going to achieve that.
But the other thing that you have to
take into consideration is it's almost
universally accepted that at least if
this world is real and if this life that
we are living is not a simulation,
it's universally accepted that this
is the pinnacle of human innovation.
That we are at the cusp where at the apex
right now and that we are at the very,
like there's more information today.
We have more knowledge.
We have more of an understanding of our
universe than any human beings before us
ever have ever.
So if that's the case,
why wouldn't we assume that we
just haven't reached it yet?
That seems to be far more likely than
the possibility that no civilization ever
achieves it.
That's why it's not there yet.
Well then we just haven't reached it
yet. Yeah, it seems way more likely.
I don't understand why
anybody would reach, uh,
a contrary conclusion if all the evidence,
whether it's cultural like watching old
television shows and comparing them to
the sophistication of today's, whether
it's musical comparing old, uh, you know,
old like Beethoven music
and old music from the 50s,
like buddy Holly type shit. And comparing
it to what people are doing today,
whether it's technological,
which is super easy and clear to,
to grasp and understand.
It's no,
there's no doubt whatsoever that were
at the apex that as far as what we can
observe, that things are,
we have more ability,
were more competent, we're more, we're
more able to alter our environment,
communicate,
et cetera.
Our technology is far more
far more complex than ever
has been at any other time
in human history that's been recorded
that we're, that we can access.
So if that's the case, why won't we just
assume that we're on this path to that?
Why would we assume that no civilization
has ever achieved it or can ever
achieve it?
That doesn't mean,
I don't assume that myself,
but I think I won.
One thing I'd throw in the ring is,
you know,
that way of looking at our history is
sort of like a linear model, right?
Like right. We've kind of, we've
got the story about, you know,
the universe started this many billion
years ago with the Big Bang and then it
sort of coalesced into whatever it
coalesced into. And eventually, you know,
life emerged a billion years ago
and evolve to be what it is now.
And we're at this sort of where at the
sort of linear progression of Ellucian
unfolding,
but that story's only like 200 years old.
So why would we assume that that
story is accurate? Um, or that,
that way of looking at it's accurate?
I mean,
it seems more likely in a hundred
years we'll have a completely,
completely different conception
of what the universe is. And,
and I wonder if part of that conception
of, part of what we'll break down,
and I'll tie this back into the
contemplative tradition because this is,
it's something that breaks
down in contemplative practice,
is the sense that time is,
uh,
exists in the way we think it exists. It
exists in a linear kind of motion, um,
time, you know, for the, for the
zen in the Zen tradition with Dogan,
his whole a chronic, like the
holographic universe, you know, there's,
all these things are contained within
themselves in this sort of a lot of these
Buddhist descriptions of
consciousness, you know, all,
all times exist simultaneously and
can be accessed simultaneously.
You know, it can be accessed
here or there. And so in that
sense, you know, the, uh,
as the, as the traditional
tech say, the Buddhas of past,
present and future all exist right now,
including ourselves.
And I don't know, that would be a very
different way of experiencing time.
I experienced it, you know, maybe like
on occasions experience it that way.
But for the most part,
that is not the way I,
I tend to think this is a
linear thing that's like,
this got to start and we'll have an end.
Well, the number one mind fuck
of all times infinity and being,
being that not only is it like,
I think especially when your children,
you know,
like you know the kids will say something
like, you know I, when times infinity,
you know what, what
infinity the, the, the,
the big mind fuck of infinity is that
not only is the concept of infinity
impossible to grasp,
but the parameters of that concept are
so strange that if infinity is real and
if the universe is infinite,
the way it's been described to me is
that everything that has ever happened on
this earth,
in the exact order has
happened on other earths,
an infinite number of times,
including every single timeline.
So right now the 1950s or going on an
infinite number of times in the exact same
order, the 1950s went on in
America, the 1950s on earth,
the 1950s are going on in the infinite
number of times in the universe as are
the 1960s as our 1961 December 21st as
our December 22nd all those days are
happening in the exact same
order with the exact same events,
exact same wards and every
possible variation in between.
So different words,
different events,
different forms of expression.
Different languages arise,
different conquers when those things are
all happening simultaneously throughout
the universe.
So everything is happening all at once.
So if infinity is correct,
like what their concept of time being
constant and happening all at once,
it is,
it's,
it is happening all at once is just the
container that holds it in his infinite.
It's,
it is a physical manifestation of this
concept and an okay question to riff off
that that I'd ask is,
and is consciousness something that's
happening to this biological being in this
one variation of the universe or is
consciousness something that moves through
this infinite potentiality and
experiences it? That's the mind fuck.
If you wake up and you're in this other
you somewhere else in the multiverse and
you know your decisions and choices
allow you to travel from one potential to
the next, but wherever you left
off where you've ever made,
maybe you were a smoker
or a drinker in the past,
or you had some sort of bad habits
and you escape those bad habits,
but not every timeline and then
at some timeline, this timeline,
well, maybe not yet. You
will after this conversation.
You know what I mean?
I mean like the idea of being that we're,
we believe that we're limited to this,
this very same physical
space in the universe because
this is where we are every
day.
But what if we transfer our consciousness
from this one to the next one and
they're indistinguishable from
each other physically to us,
but not their potential is very different.
And that in a sense,
you are dimension traveling.
And that's why we sleep.
That's why people say sleep on it,
sleep on your problems,
man.
Then maybe it'll go away in the morning
and you're just going to transfer to
another stage of you somewhere
else in the universe.
Or maybe this is more hippy bullshit.
Heinous. Hate it. When I accused
myself, rightly so of hippy bullshit.
But if,
if an infinity is correct and um,
not only do they believe that
the universe is infinite,
but they believe there are
infinite number of universes,
which is the ultimate ultimate mind fuck.
The fractal nature of reality itself.
Being that every single galaxy, which
contains hundreds of billions of stars,
has a supermassive black
hole in the center of it,
which is exactly one half of 1%
of the mass of the entire galaxy.
And if you pass through that,
you will enter into another universe
of hundreds of billions of galaxies,
each with a black hole and the center
that has a portal to another universe.
And then the whole thing just keeps
going on. So they're all the whole,
every universe is infinite.
And inside every universe is an
infinite number of universes.
And that's how big it is.
That's why every timeline
that has ever existed,
every possibility is all
happening simultaneously,
all throughout the whole thing. That's
what those Tibetans thought. Well,
they sat in a cave and just explored
their own minds. They were tripping balls.
They're probably taking something
they weren't centration were tripping
on in Dutch in history. Yeah.
That's the thing. The indogenous
drugs, like you're tripping.
Even if you're not tripping like
you, you have to, everybody does.
There's no way around it.
You're tripping when you're sleeping.
I had some trippy dreams
last night. Totally. Yeah.
Those are trips. Absolutely.
That was the trip. This is a trip.
Yes, definitely tripping right now.
I think a lot of people listen to their
trip until this people right now on a
subway going, whoa, whoa, that everything
is happening everywhere. All the time.
Like the concept of infinity,
like no, no, no. This is the,
this is a unique moment that's
unique. Not, not, not really.
Got The concept of infinity then
everything's happening right now. Yes.
Well for you,
everything is happening right now,
but the concept of infinity
is undeniable mathematically.
That's the problem is that
like you can't just ignore the,
like all you have to do
is go outside and look up.
You go outside and look up at night and
you see stars realize those are just an
impossible distance and
those are the neighbors.
Those are the ones that are really close
and if you stood on one of those stars
and looked out into the distance,
he would see stars that were equally
far away that seem equally ridiculous to
try to reach. And if you got
to those, there's no end.
You just see you're going to
keep going and going and going.
So all the evidence of infinity,
at least of the concept of great,
great distance being outside of the realm
of understanding is all it's right in
front of us every night
and a moment. Yeah. At
the, at the same time,
I think there's a way of experiencing
infinity that isn't about distance.
It's about consciousness and
infinity being, you know,
this conscious experience that
we're having right now, right.
The room that we're seeing,
the sounds that we're hearing,
the body sensations that we're having,
all of these are also arising in our
experience, right in our awareness.
And the idea of infinite distance is
a thought that arises in my awareness.
And so in some sense
there's only this awareness,
there's only this experience that we've
ever had. And so in that sense, you know,
um, the idea, the concept
of infinity as a distance,
as a great distance drops away.
And there's just this, there's just
this one moment that's happening.
I think that's what you pointing to and
there's an infinite quality to it in
terms of
that,
that the consciousness
itself is infinitely present.
It's infinitely here.
I don't know how to describe it actually,
that the consciousness is infinitely
present throughout the whole thing.
It it's undeniably the fact
that we are conscious, you know,
just like you said that the infinity is
undeniable. Consciousness is undeniable.
You know this is happening.
You cannot deny this as how, because
there's levels of consciousness, right?
There's people that are
conscious that are just, they're,
there's wandering through this live
drinking and walking into walls like are
they conscious as well and isn't that
consciousness like a very limited
consciousness and as
consciousness expands, what's the,
with the ongoing theme when we're
talking about meditation and Meditative
practices in the lightened meant,
yeah,
achieving the psychedelic states
through consciousness adjustment or
consciousness manipulation.
Like there's levels and layers
to the whole thing, right?
Yeah.
There,
there are levels and layers and there
is this unified field of consciousness
which does mount no matter what is arising
in it and how simple or complex it is.
It's just what it is.
That's why it's really strange to me
that the concept of simple biology as
opposed like complex biological
life that understand itself. Yeah.
It's simple biology of
individual cells or ma,
then multicell organisms and then the
concept of of being that's aware of itself
and can communicate over vast distances
like human beings extrapolate that a
thousand years plus
whatever it is from now.
Do we have the ability to do the same
thing with consciousness throughout the
entire universe itself?
Like is our ability to communicate over
vast distances and to communicate with
each other?
Is this just a beginning stage and
is never ending process of dissolving
boundaries where the actual
boundaries of space itself? Yeah,
no longer exist and we can interface with
intelligent life that has figured out
the same sort of shit. Yeah.
Everywhere else in the world.
The the the like universe wide web or
something. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. Yeah.
I mean if,
if the universe is infinite and the most
scientists agree it is or they believe
it is many do.
I mean it's,
it's one of those things where you
have the observable universe, right?
Which is like 14 billion light
years or something like that. But,
and then like we were talking
about with the big bang,
like it all came out of what
like Mckenna had the, the,
the best take on the big bang. He's
like, science is essentially saying,
allow us this one miracle
and we'll explain everything.
And that's really what it is.
They,
the whole universe came from something
smaller than the head of a pin. How,
um, let me get back to
you on that. But it did.
And because of that, all this stuff's
here. Well, is that a miracle?
Uh, I wouldn't know. Use that
word. You know, like, yes.
Yes it is. That's a fucking miracle, man.
If a guy can come back from the dead
after three days, that ain't shit.
The universe came out of a head of a pin.
You don't think that's more impressive
than a dude coming back from the dead.
The guy coming back from dead. Clearly
a miracle. Can we agree on that?
Walking on water, clearly a
miracle, right? Water into wine.
The motherfucker made a miracle. Right?
The universe itself is a miracle.
All of our stories about it or miracles.
Yes.
And whether or not those are just fables.
The same way the ancient Hawaiians,
the Polynesians talked about the gods
stitching the stars together with thread.
You know, maybe that's what
our concept of the big bang,
it's just our antiquated notion or are
rather primitive notion of something
that's really beyond our capacity
to understand. Yeah. That's the,
that's what the mind fuck to me. Yeah.
It's our myth. It's our, our isis.
That's our Zeus. That's our, you know,
that's our Odin is like the big bang.
Yeah.
It's just in one day they'll laugh at us.
These fucking dummies thought that the
universe was smaller than the head of a
pin and that what if for whatever reason,
man,
it just blew up and became the
universe. Yeah. One day soon probably.
Yeah, maybe. Right. Maybe,
or at least in terms of reference,
it'll,
it'll be similar to Galileo
to us. Yeah, yeah. You know,
Galileo thinking that the universe
was not centered around the earth and
everybody going, what are you
fucking crazy. Absolutely.
Like a big form point of contention and
now it's universally agreed that Galileo
was correct and everybody
else's being silly.
I there may very well come a day when
someone proposes something far more
radical than the big bang, the proves
to be true. And everybody, you know,
everybody else is like, wait, wait, what
are you saying? Hold on, hold on, hold on.
I'll give you ever seen that.
Um, there's an a, an audio of a,
I think his name is, uh, Gates and um,
William Gates, the guy who had the,
uh, the concept of a, a similar,
he has a simulation theory that he
presented to Neil degrasse Tyson.
Yeah. Yeah. That was the
president's scientific advisor.
Obama's adviser for awhile. Was He
really William Gates? Yeah. No kidding.
Um, if it's the same guys, the same guy
that found the computer codes in straight,
sort of like a Samuel L. Jackson look
alike. Yes. That's him. That's him.
And that the conversation that he has
with Neil degrasse Tyson where he says
that they found self correcting computer
code at the in the heart of string
theory. Yeah. And, and then
Neil degrasse Tyson goes, wait,
wait, wait. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Um, I want to hear the again
like say this one more time.
You found self correcting co I'm,
I'm,
I'm not sure if I understand
what you're saying.
Pull the video because that's it's uh,
we watched this for the first time last
night. Oh really? Yeah. Oh, this is,
this is one of my favorites.
I got taken down.
I gotta find out that link got taken
down. It was on reddit. Goddamn commies.
Who's doing that take?
Why would you take doctor?
Just self correcting
Computer Code Correcting
Cute Code Strength Area
Gates. Let's see. Yeah, that's it.
Strange computer code to south discovered
concealed. If you just go to the,
I found it. Just do what I just
did. I found it again. Okay.
Strange. Computer code discovered
concealed in super string equations.
This is a little bit of nonsense.
The beginning for the first 30 seconds
is like weird [inaudible] here. Play it
just that are behind your head right now.
These are pictures of equations
I've been for the last 15 years.
Trying to answer the kinds of
questions that my colleagues here,
if it happened reasoning.
And what I've come to understand is
that there are these incredible pictures
that contain all the information of a
set of equations that are related to the
string theory.
And it's even more bizarre than that
because when you then try to understand
these pictures, you find out that
buried in them, our computer codes,
just like the type that you find in
the browser when you go surf the web.
And so I'm left with a puzzle of trying
to figure out whether I live in the
matrix or not.
You're blowing my mind at this moment.
So you're saying,
are you saying if your attempt to
understand the fundamental operations of
nature leads you to a set of equations
that are indistinguishable from the
equations that drive search engines
and browsers on our computers?
That is correct.
So I'm still,
I have to just be silent
for a minute here.
So you're saying as you dig deeper,
you find
computer code written in
the fabric of the cosmos
into the equations that we want to
use to describe the cosmos. Yes.
Computer Code, Computer Code,
strings of bits of ones and Zeros.
It's not just sort of
resembles computer code.
You're saying it is computer code.
It's not even just his computer code.
It's a special kind of computer code
that was invented by a scientist named
Claude Shannon and the 1940s
that's what we find very,
very deeply inside the equations that
occur in string theory and in general in
systems that we get caught
say are supersymmetric
time to go home.
I think where are we going to go?
So are you saying we are all just,
there's some entity that programmed the
universe and we're just expressions of
their code?
Well I didn't say that
like the Matrix.
Do you think about what you said those
codes are showing on the screen and
behind you right now they don't look like
codes,
but these pictures which we call a dink
groves or graphical representations of
sets of equations that are based on codes.
So this is in fact,
to answer your question more directly,
I have in my life come to a very strange
place because I never expected that the
movie, the Matrix might be an
accurate of the place in which I live.
Well, Dan give you an argument
that we don't live in the matrix
please to quick very simple argument.
There's a property that the
real world right down here,
cause that no mathematical
equation hasn't,
no solution of the
equation has it? No. Okay.
That no abstract object has here in the
real world. It is always some moment,
which is one of a series of passing
moments in a mathematical equation doesn't
have a flow of time in it.
It just is.
And this means but Lee,
but I need him here and now
this means that to me that the,
the,
the ancient metaphysical fantasy
that we quote are just mathematics.
Okay? CanNot be true because in a
world that was just mathematics,
there would be no moment of
time as a function of time.
It's a differential equations.
But then you lay the solution out.
Taking, you keep using the word is, and
I'm talking about the word describe.
Okay.
You see the whole drive is
fine, but let me, let me finish
please. Since we started with
my discussion point is that I,
I,
you know,
it's fun to talk about some
deep metaphysical essence
that sits behind physics
before some of us,
it's about trying to find the most
accurate way to describe where we live.
And so my statement is that in
the description of our universe,
that is a super symmetrical universe
which we were going to test in the LHC.
If you believe that description, I can
show you the presence of these codes.
That's my statement.
I'm fucked.
I can't,
can't go on shows over.
What do you say to that?
Like you, you listen to what these guys
have just described and talked about.
I disagree with the one guy saying that
because we live in this moment in this,
there's like this linear pattern to
things that it can't be a mathematical
equation. That's not true. That doesn't
make any sense. That's like saying, um,
if there is a car and the car is driving
on a road that has been created by
people, if it's, you know, if it's going
from one distance, if it's traveling,
that it can't possibly be an artificially
created an environment that doesn't
make any sense to me.
It's like you're traveling through this
thing just because you're experiencing
the now and it's progressive and you
know the past and you were looking to
forward to the future and you're
moving and you're in this mode.
That doesn't mean it's not
a mathematic representation.
Well,
what comes to mind is that a lot of
times in our formulas are our mathematic
equations that I'm not a mathematician.
It's the mind tendency is to
lock down on the variables,
but then it locks it down.
So it's constantly changing.
What do you mean by that?
Meaning that we have,
there is a tendency of mine to like to
go into concepts as if they were solid
and as if they were fixed and any kind
of time that we do that we locked down
the possibility. So if we can relax
into whatever it's representing,
then that representation can continue to
be fluid and so therefore there's a lot
of space and a lot of room to continue
and the present moment is not just one
thing.
I just don't understand
the argument that if,
if mathematics are, if, if it's,
I guess he's trying to say in
a sense that because we're,
we experienced individual moments,
we have this moment,
we're in this moment and
that it's progressive that
this wouldn't be the case if
it was a mathematical equation.
That doesn't make any sense to me.
Maybe I'm just too dumb,
but it seems to me that that leaves
out the possibilities of yes,
you could do that or yes you could.
It could be a mathematical equation
that you are experiencing or it could be
that this idea of this computer code
that they're finding is just simply a lot
like so many other codes that
we found and things that, that,
that indicate that nature has
some sort of a pattern to it.
Like the FIBONACCI
sequence. Like, you know,
the idea that these codes
that exist in nature,
they're there, they don't exist
because this is artificial,
but they exist because nature
essentially runs on mathematics.
So is nature artificial or is it what?
I don't think anything has artificial
or you can say everything's artificial.
Yeah,
well everything is natural.
There's like everything on earth
including like artificial chemicals were
produced from things that are
naturally occurring on earth.
And human beings are a natural creation
of the earth or of biological life
itself and all the byproducts of
human beings including things that we
considered to not be natural.
Our natural,
just like a beehive is a natural
creation of a B. You know,
nuclear waste is the natural creation
of the inquisitive human being. It's,
they're not natural, but they are
natural cause everything is natural.
They don't exist outside of our
manipulation, but we are a part of nature.
So essentially all of our
creations are in fact natural.
I make this argument so often to
try to undercut the notion that um,
using technology to uh,
develop your ability to contemplate
the universe in consciousness,
uh, that, that somehow is unnatural. I
use that all the time but I'm thinking,
you know, you could, you could say the
same thing. Like everything is artificial.
Everything is generated from
something else. You know,
the big bang came from somewhere.
The mathematical formulas and the
starting conditions came from some non
physical place outside of this universe.
And so therefore they're
artificial from this perspective.
But I think that's the same saying the
same thing as everything is natural,
everything is artificial
and everything is natural.
Yeah. Everything is
natural. I think it's the,
we have this idea of natural
and artificial that we
described with our foods.
You know,
we describe it with are the things that
are healthy and non healthy about what
we've created in our culture.
But it's when you start using those same
terms to describe human creation and
then you start understanding the nature
of human innovation and creativity in
the first place. Like boy, I don't
know if that's natural or not.
How could it be any less natural than an
octopus changing its shape to hide or,
you know, changing. It's a skin tone
to blend in with the environment.
Isn't that natural?
It's an artificial looked at the octopus
is created in order to camouflage
itself from predators or prey.
What do you,
what do you think people are really
pointing to when they say something's
unnatural?
Like what do you think they're really
getting at are really trying to say it's
bad. It's bad. Yeah. We
gotta go back in time,
go back to chopping wood and, sure.
Yeah. It's bad according to what?
Like according to what set of values or
what conception of what the good is good
in the universe.
Right.
I think we're constantly instantiating
our utopias through, you know,
what we, how we live in what we
do. And like we're constantly
deluding ourselves into thinking
our conception of the universes.
The correct conception.
Hmm. And, and, and, but,
but I'm like, we can't help it. Like
I cannot help but say, you know,
I think this is the most important
thing. Compassion, wisdom. You know,
like I've got my own conception of
what's most important. But is there a
most important, I mean, is
the word most important?
The problem where the definition
of most important? The problem.
Because what is most important to you
is not most important to others. Right.
It's like it's a very personal
idea of what's most important.
What's most important to starving people
right now is getting them food and
water.
Right.
What's most important to the president
is figuring out what to do about Israel
and Gaza. What's most important? You know,
there's like what is most
important is a very personal thing.
Yeah. And yet there seem
to be patterns, you know,
like people have certain values and,
and share those values with others and
there's a collective code that seems to
be running as well.
Yeah. And again, it boils back to
what, what is that collective code?
What's the purpose of it all?
Yeah. To facilitate society,
civilization and to move forward
with the progression of innovation
till we become robots.
Until he figured out a way
to get out of here. I mean,
trend is obviously there, right? The
symbiotic connection that we have to,
you know, you don't want
even leave your phone behind.
You want to keep that sucker on you.
If you leave it behind,
you feel like you left a part of you back
there. Yeah. Oh my God. I left my hand.
You know, I got to go back
and get my hand. I mean, it's
almost similar. Yeah. My, uh,
outer outer cortex. Yeah. There's
a, there's something weird to that.
Does something says
something weird to our,
our desire that this
Marshall Mcluhan's idea,
but we're the sex objects
of the machine world,
that what we're doing is we're giving
birth like a caterpillar becoming a
butterfly.
We're unaware of our actions really
ultimately being a part of this transition
from the monkey body into
this new transcendent thing.
But then,
then the big question is,
what is that and what's the purpose
of that? And if we do become that,
does it just sit? Does it say,
what's the point moving? No,
I'm just going to sit here. What's the
point in innovating? There's no need.
What's the point in creating new ones
to what do more of nothing? Fuck it.
It's,
it just sits there.
So we show up on some planet someday
and there's like these super complex
artificial beings that were created by
biological beings and then they just
stopped and they all just sat around
waiting for the next stage of existence.
And it never came
in Buddhist cosmology actually
it's described that way.
Yeah. Actually the, uh,
there's six realms in the Buddhist
cosmology and one of the realms is the God
realm.
And in the God realm,
the gods literally just abide in his
formless awareness for like eons and eons
and eons. But at some
point the story goes, um,
something changes and they die.
They do have,
they also are born and die,
does formless realms aren't,
aren't permanent.
And so the,
at some point they like come
out of it and then they die.
Then they get reborn
into some other realm.
Well, if you stop and think about the
birth and death of stars and planets,
if these artificial
beings live on planets,
they have a life time,
a lifespan,
whether they like it or not because
they're very solar system they exist in,
is dependent upon that. Star burning
a finite amount of fuel, right?
Whether it's 500 billion years or whatever
the hell your stars gotten its tank,
when that sucker is out, it's going
to Supernova. And that's a wrap son.
There's no more artificial intelligence
on that rock that's spinning around in
space.
And the question is,
does the artificial intelligence that
exists recognize that and feel the need to
protect itself from this finite existence
by building a spaceship and traveling
physically traveling from
dimension to dimension
or traveling within the dimension of
consciousness and looking for a resolution
there,
but does it have consciousness once
it becomes artificial, what is con?
Is consciousness purely something that
the universe is created and we can't?
Oh, I doubt that. Really. Yeah. You think
we'll be able to recreate consciousness?
I think if we, I mean I'm, I'm,
this is just a kind of guests,
but I think if we create a suitable
substrate for consciousness,
consciousness will appear. And that's
based on my assumption that, you know,
consciousness appears. Where
wait, where there's something
happening. There's some sense of it,
of Kering to something.
Well, it depends on what we're
calling consciousness. Yeah,
I use it in a simple way,
like just basic awareness,
like just kind of the awareness of like
being in this room of, of, of sight,
of sound. So animal and even insects
have consciousness in that sense.
And Alford North
head, you know, he,
he sort of presumed that even Adams
have a most fundamental sense of
consciousness that he called prehension.
Mm. Um, and I don't know if that's,
it's kind of like a pantheistic
perspective, but um, I,
I think everything is imbued at the most
fundamental level with consciousness.
But that's,
that's probably because I've been spent
my whole life exploring consciousness.
Well, you, when you say everything, do
you mean like physical objects as well?
Like a desk? Like does this
desk have consciousness? Yeah,
look at the most basic level,
some form of,
but non measurable.
So completely just
conscious.
Radical consciousness is consciousness.
Consciousness isn't by
definition immeasurable.
You can't measure consciousness
because it's not a quantity.
Right. Why would you assume that in and
out of it? An object's possess it then.
Okay.
It's,
it's sort of just comes from a comp comes
from the deepest states of meditation
that I've experienced.
This kind of sense of knowing
that everything is at the fund,
that most fundamental level consciousness
itself and so that there isn't
something outside of consciousness.
You know,
Adam's couldn't exist outside
of consciousness. It's just,
it's just a felt sense I guess.
It's hard to describe.
Like I don't have like a
really solid argument for it
and even if something
appears solid at a very
microscopic level,
we can see things moving around.
Like even though this table feels solid,
it's not completely solid.
Right, of course. Yeah. Every
atom is mostly air empty space.
Yeah.
So at a sense like you know,
I've had experiences too
where the concentration
becomes so strong that things
just start to break down and
everything seems to be dissolving and
reconstructing and dissolving
and reconstructing.
It isn't just, just the perceptions of
your own mind, isn't this just the, the,
your, your mind has this
ability to perceive its a,
its surroundings and its environment.
And in meditation you're altering
the parameters, you're changing the,
the influences, your, you're
changing the physical state,
the flow of the neurotransmitters and
all these different things are changing
how you view the environment itself.
But you're not really changing
the environment at all.
Yeah. Mitigates, it depends on
how you look at it. Cause no,
I mean I'm not changing it and then yes,
I am changing it by doing
this particular practices.
You're changing it in that
you're changing your perceptions,
perceptions changed the
way your interface with it.
Yeah. I think this goes back
to the paradox of like it
is very paradoxical. Yeah.
Like the paradox of, you know, do it,
can we describe this from the outside
objective objectively and like that's the
most true perspective
or do we describe it as,
as the subjective conscious
experience of it and on which mode,
which is more true.
And I keep going back to like you can't
reduce one to the other or conflate one
to the other. Um, entirely.
Otherwise you basically are just sort of
propping up a particular perspective as
the ultimate truth. Um, I dunno, I think,
I think there's something completely
disenchanted about seeing everything as
physical objects and,
and this as a kind of just
like hallucination to make
us feel better so we can
continue to propagate.
I think there's something fundamentally
wrong about that on the level of being a
conscious being. And yet I also
see, you know, the tendency for um,
people to conflate their own experiences
with the external universe as being
like highly problematic
too. That's a funny, yeah.
Word.
Disenchanted.
That's a funny way of cause it is,
you know,
it is kind of your, your, the
way your perception of it.
Okay.
Is that it's almost like
this mystical view of it.
This is beautiful,
airy fairy view of it and
makes it more exciting.
And so like to think of them is to think
of it and more stoic terms or more,
you know, more, um, I don't know
what the word I would use, just more,
more clearly defined terms.
It's like not as fun.
Does that make sense? It does. Um,
it's also,
I think like Emily was saying,
like the moment we solidify reality,
then like we lose the background,
you know,
that we'd lose the sense that
we don't actually completely know that
every story we've ever told, you know,
as a species has ended up being wrong
at some level. You know, it's not,
it's not actually did like the big bang.
You know,
at some point we're going to realize that
story was the best story we could come
up with to describe the evolution of the
physical universe or the development of
it or whatever. But at
some point, you know,
we're going to discover something
that just blows our minds again,
and then we're gonna have to come up
with a new story that can make sense of
that and, and we're going to
get solidified about that.
We're going to think, oh,
that's the way it really is.
Hmm.
And so I think there's something
about certainty, you know,
and really thinking we have it worked
out that it becomes problematic at some
level.
That's kind of the
beauty of existence, right?
Is that there's a lot of
mystery to this thing, right?
Yeah. It's like half the half the fun.
Right? Exactly. Yes. A disenchantment.
Like it's part of that right
comes from like,
I feel like people can get disconnected
from their hearts and that can be airy
fairy too, but it's, it's that is real to,
to be up in the mind and the brain
and then forget that there is,
there is the feelings and the
tenderness and the vulnerability in a,
in a positive way. Cause there's actually
a lot of power in the vulnerability. So,
um,
there's some sort of balance that I think
it comes in to play from some of the
eastern traditions and then some of
the western traditions because I,
I feel that balance too in the room as
we're talking, um, between, you know,
opening more into the mystical part
of things and then also, you know,
needing to concept, naming the
rational mind, needing the science. Um,
and where is that balance in our
modern world? I don't, I'm not sure.
Well, yeah, that's the
real question, right?
Where's the balance in the modern world?
Because the modern world is
essentially without balance.
That's the number one criticism of
it is that we're raping the earth and
torturing our,
our,
our planet and robbing it of its resources
and polluting the oceans and all that
jazz.
And that there isn't a balance to it all.
And that the experience is
just what it is for you.
You,
you know,
you live this life and your perceptions
and your ideas are essentially what
flavor it for you. And if you, if
you choose to be mister no nonsense,
you still die. You know, you live, you
die and that's it. And you saw blind spot.
Yeah. You still limitations.
Yeah, most certainly.
And um, the, the,
the concept of consciousness in this
way is more empowering or at least gives
you a better feeling about the life
that you're living and may enhance that
experience, may make that
experience a more pleasurable ride
and it may impact others around you
cause a mirror and everything else.
Yeah. Well, definitely, you know, when
I'm around people that are super positive,
I feel better. It's this,
that's undeniable. I don't
understand it, but I do,
you know, inherently this is like a
part of you that grasps it. But, uh,
it's undeniable. And when you're around
pessimistic people, it's a huge drag.
That's a huge drag to be
around super negative people.
Like I remember I had this really negative
girlfriend once when I broke up with
her. I remember dropping her
off and driving away going,
oh my God,
I'm free.
What if there was a, uh, a side
of things? It was negative.
She would find it and
just start pecking at it,
eh. And B, what about fat
man? Oh, it was brutal.
It was brutal. And that, that, you know,
if you can find the opposite of that,
find someone who's got a good take. Like,
Hey, this is what it is. But from here,
well, we can learn to never do that again.
And so this is an awesome blessing and
that we've learned a lesson from this and
we're going to move forward.
And you know,
we still have love and
community and friendship and
there's a lot of people that
look at things that way and there's
so much more fun to be around.
It just makes the experience
of life itself more exciting
and in that sense what
we,
what people are doing with Buddhism or
TM or spending a lot of time in isolation
tanks or it's sort of a
workaround for biology, sort of a,
a framework for developing your
consciousness as you manage your biology.
Does that make sense? Yeah, I think
that's a valid way of talking about it.
We might've run out of mind fucks
in this podcast. I think we hit it.
We hit a wall self correcting
Peter Code at James Gates and Neil Tyson,
my thrown us into a wall.
It's just too, how did you guys get
involved in all this stuff? Like what,
what made you gravitate
towards this as a young person?
Is it just something you discovered
early on and sort of slowly but surely it
became a massive part of your life?
Um, for I think for, for both
of us, that's probably true.
I won't speak for Emily,
but uh, for, for me, I grew
up with hippie parents,
you know, uh, new agey parents.
And so the notion of meditation
and consciousness was,
was kind of part of the dialectic
growing up. Where'd you grow up?
I grew up in Asheville,
North Carolina.
Aww. I love that place. That's
where Dunkin's from. Yeah.
That's where we live now.
You guys live there?
Yeah. Place is so awesome.
I don't want to tell people about
it. So awesome. When I was there,
I was walking down the street.
I was like, this is like,
it doesn't exist in anywhere else. The
word's getting out, believe me. Dammit.
Yeah. Now it's really out. That
place is amazing. That's an amazing,
amazing town. It's
quite interesting. Yeah.
It's so unusual.
Like I was there with a buddy and
we'll Dunkin and another buddy of mine,
we were walking on the street and go
into this restaurant and then we went to
this bar. I was like, where
else is there a place like this?
It's like this small town
of really likeminded folks.
Very Open minded, very
progressive, but very small.
What's the population there?
A Hundred K I think it isn't.
So it's very boulder sized. That's which
is another similar town like that. Yeah.
It's very sad. But you guys are
like tucked up in the mountains.
Well we're, we're in a hauler. The
hauler. We like it. Yeah. That's amazing.
How'd you get there? Um, I
grew up just outside of there,
a little town called Mars hill
and I grew up two hours away.
And Wilkesboro small town. Yes. And
you gravitated towards Asheville.
How well we, we actually lived in
boulder for about a decade. Really? Yeah.
We were working,
she was working at Naropa University.
I went to school there. Oh, that's
that freaky hippie university. Right.
Buddhist inspired we,
we call it the Buddhist inspired Harvard.
They have a class in Zen flower
arrangement. You Cubana. Yeah.
It didn't take that one, but
I like, this is hilarious.
You get an accredited class
and Zen flower arrangement.
The only place that I know of. Yeah. Yeah.
Which is also a kind of similar, it's
kind of similar kind of vibe. Yeah.
Boulder most certainly does.
And another place that's tucked in the
mountains and it's like there's something
about mountains that are so humbling,
like you just look at it like
you can't be that important.
Are you seeing what I'm seeing? Like
your daily life and troubles? They,
they are balanced in perspective by the
images that you're seeing of the most
spectacular versions of
art that nature's created.
And then that's what the mountains are
to me, like snow covered, tree covered,
whatever.
They are seeing a lake at the bottom of
a canyon and just like nature's stunning
works of art.
And the,
the just the sheer vast magnitude of them,
like the Rockies forces people
to sort of humility. Oh yeah.
Sort of like beach towns,
you know like why are beach towns,
so why is everybody so chill by the beach?
We'll look at that fucking ocean, man.
Who are you? How are you taking yourself
so seriously, look at that thing.
It's fast.
You can't see the end and it's all
water and it's moving up and back.
And at any point in time it could just
rise up and a thousand mile high swell
and take out the entire
planet. That's right. Yeah.
There's something about nature
that's like super important. So I,
people that live in a, in a place where
they don't get a chance to see it,
you know,
in New York City in a sense is humbling
in its own way because as we said,
everything is natural.
You know,
human beings creating cities are
not much different than a beehive.
It's just we're way better at making shit
than bees are. So we make skyscrapers.
But when you're in Manhattan,
like, uh, last time I was there,
I was staying at this hotel and we
were pretty high up and uh, you know,
you open up your window and you look out
the window like, whoa, this is crazy.
This is so futuristic and bizarre.
We're in the middle of it.
Like all the buildings are around us.
We're seeing all these people moving
around inside of their windows.
Some of them I'm sure with binoculars,
telescopes and shit peering out at all
the different stories that are playing
out in the various little
cubicles and boxes around them.
Absolutely. Yeah. But,
um, I think that, uh, the,
the, at least to me, the most
peaceful version of that, those, the,
you know, that kind of imagery
is the natural version,
the real natural version as far as like
non men created I should say. You know,
the, the mountains and there's
something about it like,
especially like a place like Asheville
or a place like boulder sort of like, uh,
it,
yeah.
It's just defined by its environment.
Yeah.
Okay.
So, um, the Buddhist geeks thing,
one of the things that I thought that
was interesting that you said that I find
too is that you start doing it and people
start getting connected to it and then
you feel like you kind of stuck
in it like a in that like, boy,
I have a responsibility now
people are enjoying this.
Yes. Getting maybe, hopefully
getting some value from it.
Yeah. Well it at the very least
being entertained on a bus, you know,
or on a plane or, or what have you.
Are you stuck in a commute? You know,
at the very least it's that. Yeah.
How often you guys do it? Huh?
We do a podcast once a week,
so we do like a interview like
this or a conversation like this,
probably once a week.
Now when you do those,
do you prepare for them?
Like do you have like a theme or do you
have like questions that you lay out
beforehand and
usually, yeah, usually it's a, with a,
with a person or group that, you know,
we're exploring a particular topic like,
um,
and we've explored a lot around the
interface of technology and Buddhist
practice,
um,
various intersection points of how
Buddhism is sort of interfacing with
psychology and science and technology
and you know, various aspects of culture.
So we'll usually kind of go into one of
those intersection points and explore it
with someone who's really been working at
that interface. And so who is, you know,
in some ways the most, um, informed
and
in terms of their ignorance about what's
going on at that interface and just
kind of explore it and see what happens.
Um,
and can you give me example of like one
of the recent episodes read today? Yeah,
sure. So we recently, uh, I talked to, um,
a neuroscientist named David Wago who's
at Harvard and he's a contemplative
neuroscientists. Um, and Jake Davis,
who's a Buddhist cognitive philosopher,
and we sort of explored some of their
recent work around finding and discovering
a neuroscience of enlightenment.
Um,
and they've been sort of
working with the question,
is there a neuroscience of enlightenment?
Can we see what enlightenment and
quotes looks like in the brain?
Um, and is that even possible
philosophically? Like,
is it enlightenment one thing
or is it many things? Um,
and so we really just went through and
explored some of their ideas around
enlightenment. What is it, uh,
what conceptions are they using? A,
what have they found
in their, in their, um,
in their research because David's been
working a lot with, um, folks, uh,
like Shinzen young who has been
meditating for 40 years and who you know,
has a really, you know, kind of, um,
complex system of meditation
and mindfulness practice
and it's something that he
designed to be able to be
scientifically studied.
So they've been sort of putting advanced
meditators and various fmri machines
and sort of seeing what happens
when they do various kinds of tasks,
seeing what happens when they have
these kind of peak moments, you know,
what actually is occurring in the,
in the nervous system,
seeing if they can come up with a model
to describe that. Neuroscientifically
that's fascinating.
The Fmr Ri is a really interesting stuff.
Oh yeah.
And
have you ever been in one?
It's so weird. No, no.
It's like a shamonic drum beating
through your head. Really.
It's really bizarre.
And when I,
when we got in there for one of these
meditation studies afterwards, I was like,
are they taking into account the fact
that the FMRI machine itself is like a
completely altered state experience?
It's just a huge magnet. Your, yeah.
I've been in an MRI before. She's similar.
You hear that tone, Dum, Dum, Dum,
Dum.
Yeah.
This one had like the
one we went to like had,
I mean what sounded like drum beats and
all kinds of weird stuff. I mean, I was,
wow. Yeah. I mean, I don't know
if it was like that for you now.
That's what it sounded like. Yeah, yeah.
It was weird.
Yeah.
I talked to a neuroscientist and they
were explaining that there's some issues
with Fmr eyes where they're,
they're trying to use them for a crime
investigation and they're being used by
people who don't understand the
limitations of the technology.
So someone was accused
of a crime in India,
crew accused of murder
and convicted by an Fmr.
I result because the FMRs showed
functional knowledge of the crime scene.
Ooh, yeah. Ooh, exactly.
And she was very concerned about this
because her perceptions of it where you
could by reviewing the case itself
and by reviewing the information,
you could give someone functional
knowledge of a crime scene without them
actually having been there while the
crime scene was going on. And that,
so if you could read that there's
functional knowledge of a crime scene,
it doesn't mean that the
person is actually been there
while the crime was being
played out.
I mean there's,
there's people that have
functional knowledge of all
sorts of places like Mount
Rushmore and put,
you know,
like if you play that in some folks head
that are like deeply studied history
and been paying a lot of tension,
you might be able to show some sort of a
functional knowledge of the area itself.
If they have, specially if they have
a vested interest in studying this,
like they're being accused of a murder,
you know,
you would think there'd
be a lot of intensity and
emotional connection to that.
But these concepts like all these
different things is when it comes to
technology and the understanding
of the human brain.
There's so they're evolving right now in
front of us so rapidly. Yeah, it's true.
I mean
just recently in the
contemplative neuroscience field,
they discovered that when you're not
doing anything that is like your baseline
state, that you are in fact doing
something. And they just sort of,
that was one of the big insights that
came out of a contemplative neuroscience
was that the default mode network of the
brain is actually the selfing network.
It's the network that is constantly
constructing the sense of identity and
referencing one self even when you're not
doing anything. So that was, you know,
the assumption prior to that was just
like, when you're not doing anything,
nothing's happening. Um, but no,
actually a lot of stuff's happening.
It's like yourself program
is running basically.
Yeah. What, what? Well, we don't
understand. What the fuck is,
is that self program.
That's the problem.
How much of that is just
keeping the heart beating?
How much of that is maintaining a normal
state without freaking out and ripping
your clothes off,
running into traffic,
and what causes you to freak out and
rip your clothes off and running into
traffic.
And do you find that having these shows
and doing all these podcasts has given
you a like a window that you would
have normally not had before?
Oh, totally, totally.
I can't separate now out the experience
of talking to all these people and
exploring some of the topics that we
explore from my experience now of how I
understand the world, it's
just, it's so intertwined.
I'm sure you can kind of relate to that.
Yeah.
That's why I wanted to ask you because
it becomes like a part of your life is
not just about having these conversations
but about broadcasts in these
conversations. Yeah. And exploring them,
not just through your own curiosity but
through trying to either a luminate or
figure out a way to express these ideas
across where you think they're going to
be accepted or understood the best.
Understood is probably the
best way to describe it.
Like the way it's going to interface
with the most amount of people. Yeah,
I mean sometimes I think it's one of the
most grandiose things to do is to start
a podcast or to start, you
know, to be a media person.
And I sometimes wonder
if I myself as a result,
just being a,
he started the podcast seven years ago,
so I've kind of been on the periphery
of it and just watching it from the
outside perspective too.
It's fairly interesting to see how like
his podcasts and the stuff that he talks
about in his own development as,
I don't know if you can relate to it has
really come across in each episode as
it's, and now we have an archive of seven
years of like development of, you know,
his own understanding and then how
everything just kind of co like converges.
Now we're really
exploring the convergence.
Well,
the beautiful thing about a podcast is
that you don't have someone telling you
what the subject of today's going to be.
You don't have someone telling you this
is what you should be interested in.
You know,
you,
you find these unique individual visions
because a podcast and some of them are
ridiculous, stupid and some
of them are awesome, you know,
and what's ridiculously stupid
to me is awesome to someone else.
And that's the kind of the beauty of
podcasting and it goes along with what
we're talking about. I think when it
comes to technology and social media,
it's like the, the interfacing with ideas,
the ability to exchange information.
It's all sort of radically changing
right in front of us. And you know,
podcasting is just a part of
that. Absolutely. How, um,
how do you feel like you're going
to take this thing into the future?
Do you have any plans for it? Are you
trying to expand it or you are you, uh,
you're nodding virtual, virtual
reality's next? I think like Oculus,
oculus rift style, podcasting.
Well, I mean, part of it, well,
that could happen.
Um, we'll see if that's popular, but Geez,
you know, I think, uh, you know, for us,
you know, we're doing Buddhist geeks as a
media project, but we're also, you know,
meditation teachers and we work a lot
with other folks. Um, and we've trained,
you know, with, with various
Buddhist teachers. So for us,
we're wanting to make a space both for,
you know,
these conversations but also for
people to practice together, um,
in virtual space.
So that's a lot of our focus lately is
on how to reinvent the Buddhist practice
tradition for the 21st century.
And a big part of that that we're working
on now is, is doing retreats online,
you know,
periods of intensive,
immersive practice that happened in the
context of your life. And also, you know,
we're building what we're
conduct Buddhist geeks Dojo,
which is going to be kind of,
we're describing it as an early version
of the Matrix for training your mind,
the Buddhist geeks Dojo, the Buddhist
geeks Doge, and what does that entail?
What's going to be in there?
It'll,
it'll be at least a place for people to
meditate together to talk about what's
happening in their practice,
which basically as their life,
and to find a community of folks who
are kind of on a similar journey of,
of cultivating certain kinds of states
of mind and certain understandings.
Why Buddhism though? Or why
not? Why call it something?
Is that where it gets me when you're
talking about rebelling against Buddhism,
right?
Yeah.
Well we've rebelled and we've rebelled
against her and rebellion currently.
Yeah. I mean it's like if we don't call
it Buddhism, we'll call it something else.
And then there's a framework around that.
And so it's like,
I can't get outside of the framework
no matter how smart or a framework,
no matter how hard I try and my training
and has been with some really awesome
people in the Buddhist tradition and I'm
not going to be able to just let that,
you know, it's always going
to impact me and influence me.
And there's something about the flavor
of that tradition and what it reveals,
hippies
changing and it's changing. Look, I mean
it's changed.
You guys are changing it a little
bit because of technology and you're
interfacing with technology. I mean, yeah,
I mean, we're just a small part of it.
I mean, how else is it changing? I mean,
the science is coming in
really influencing it. The
mindfulness movement is very
much influenced, again, you
could call mindfulness a
form of secular Buddhism. Um,
I mean, certainly the
guy that, that had it,
that's had the most impact
on the mindfulness movement.
Jon Kabat Zinn was spent,
you know, a number of decades studying
Buddhism in India and Asia. So, I mean,
those things are very big shifts in
terms of how it's being practiced and the
context that it's being held
in. And, well, that's funny
that you said the secular,
because most people would
consider Buddhism to be a,
some sort of a, or maybe one
of the only saccular religions.
And it's, it's true in some
cases, in other cases, it's,
it's like a lot of other religions,
a lot of what's the
creepiest forms of Buddhism?
It must be, throw him under the bus,
creepiest for feel good. What's,
what's the most dogmatic, the
most, uh, ideology filled?
I mean, I must be right there.
I think Bikram Yoga. No,
I mean there are lots
of forms that you know,
that are very rigid in terms
of how they're taught and
what to believe when you
do them.
I mean,
I think that's hard to escape in a
certain way because when people find
something that was really powerful and
works, they get really fixated on it.
Right? Like wearing orange robes.
Yeah. Like wearing orange robes,
although that's not really
that popular anymore,
at least in its current form in the west.
It,
monasticism is not
definitely not taking off.
So that's one way it's changing.
Also,
it's moved away from monasticism
and toward this more kind of, um,
lay centered life,
that being integrated with everyone else
being integrated in your life. You know,
how it is. And that's, I think that's true
of most religions that are doing well.
It's like they've,
they've moved away from the transcendent
and toward the imminent. You know,
they've,
they're reconceiving divinity as something
that exists in your life as it is.
It's not something that's beyond
your life in some way that,
that something's wrong with your life or
your, you know, your body that, you know,
this is a sin full, terrible vessel
that is completely limited. I mean,
and it is in one sense,
but in another sense like that's just,
that's an intermediary insight from,
from, you know, from my experience,
what are the confining aspects of calling
it Buddhism though? Like what, what is,
what are the pitfalls
of that besides hippies?
You definitely going to
get some problematic if not
that, oh, I love hippies.
Don't get me wrong. Yeah. Same Pete
hippies come in many shades. There's,
there's legit hippies and then there's
like really annoying hippies that just
sort of, you know, the, they use the
hippie framework to just be annoying.
[inaudible] sure. I mean, I'll,
I'll say one can finding thing is that um,
Buddhism as a religion,
I mean at least in terms of how we
understand religion, is it tax free? Uh,
is it tax free?
Yeah.
Do you have tax free exemption the
same way that other religions too? We,
we personally don't, but you
could, you could do that. Yeah.
You'll give fucking chase down.
Don't do it.
It gets really, really hairy
when you don't want to pay
taxes. They go, oh, really?
Time to take a little closer.
Look at the Buddhist Geek Organization.
See what you're doing on Saturday
nights there. Infiltrate.
Yeah. I think with anything like
Buddhism, I mean you inherit,
but choosing that framework,
we inherit all, we inherit it.
And so there's a lot about,
um,
religions and spirituality
in general that is not,
that I don't personally
like, you know, so, um,
I think that there is a,
there's a tendency to project,
I mean you brought in the word divinity,
so I'll use it like to
project our divinity onto the
teachers are onto some sort
of system and um,
it can disempowering for a lot of people.
People can get trapped and beliefs that,
you know,
we've had been carried forward for, you
know, years and centuries that aren't,
isn't forwarding anymore.
Um,
and so that sense like by choosing to go
under Buddhism, we're also choosing to,
you know, work on how we can
evolve, how we think about it.
And one thing that I really like is the,
is the practices themselves,
um,
the mind training aspect of it.
That's what's been really beneficial
to me and that's one of the reasons why
I've chosen to continue
because if its impact,
the mind training aspects
of it. Like what, what,
what,
what do you think is like the tangible
benefits of this mind training aspect of
it that you personally experience?
Personally I can say
personally I feel much,
much more, much more open. I'm
much more generous, compassionate.
There's a lot more freedom I can get
stuck on the smaller sense of self.
Meaning,
you know,
I have these thoughts of like unworthiness
or self contraction or hatred or any
of those, you know,
biological kind of urges.
And at the same time they're so
transient and they're so not who I am.
And I see that very,
very clearly that it kind of
diminishes in just a second.
I'm on the good days.
Sometimes it's more intense and I've
learned to really work with that and learn
how to see clearly what's happening so
that I have the freedom to really choose
how to live my life in
a much more full way.
So really is like a work around for a
lot of the biological pitfalls I think.
So I think it's a way of working
with the situation as it is.
And then making the most of it. If
someone came along with another name, no,
like Buddhist, like the word, the word
Buddhist. If someone came along with, uh,
another name for a similar practice,
do you think that it would be accepted?
Yeah,
there's some,
I think the Buddhist tradition and
especially in the West has been modified,
like mindfulness based stress reduction.
I mean,
some of these different techniques are
taking from the ancient techniques. Um,
there's something about grooves and
consciousness and patterns like we were
talking about earlier.
So by going under Buddhism,
we're kind of riding in those grooves
and they're not all bad, you know?
Yeah, no, there's something, I don't
know if my own experience, and this,
it's a little embarrassing in a secular
context to talk about this because it,
it's weird to say,
you know,
for whatever reason I just fell in
love with the forms and the, and the,
the ritual and the, you know,
and the, just the feel of it,
the aesthetic of Buddhism.
I first, for some reason,
I just immediately felt a sense of
being at home when I went to the first
meditation retreat and I was there
practicing and I was like, oh wow.
And I felt this deep sense of
connection with that particular form.
And for whatever reason, it just
like it for me, it unlocked a lot,
very rapidly that I don't know that would
have been otherwise possible if I was
trying to do some sort of practice that
I didn't really connect with that much.
You know, something about just the love
of the form and the aesthetic itself, uh,
that I can't really explain except
that I've always liked Asian stuff
and the inclining of the mind towards,
um, awakenings or awakening, you know,
that framework and itself
as it's an interesting, um,
inclination. So, you know, just like
we had search for the holy grail,
we mentioned that earlier,
the inclination towards some
kind of inquiry into okay.
And the question presented itself
earlier, like who, who is, who are we,
who is this?
Um,
and I've found that the techniques and
the forms have been really revealing in
that way.
The deification of the teachers
are real issue though, right? The,
they're really does become an issue with
any time any person is the distributor
of knowledge or information.
They take this position yes.
And elevated as challenging. And I
think the best teachers, you know,
we're learning as we become hopefully
a little better as teachers,
is that the best teachers use that
situation to help people kind of gain a
confidence in their own
experience and to be able to, um,
no freedom for themselves
through their own practices.
Of paying attention,
of being with things and in that sense
that the best teachers are the ones that
make themselves irrelevant.
Um, to the best teachers.
The best teachers make themselves
completely irrelevant I think.
And process can be empowering in itself.
Yeah.
Everyone's so calm. Involvement. The,
did the Buddhist ever get into like death
metal or driving too fast or, oh yeah.
Racing cars driving too fast. You got,
hold it. There's a whole movement in the,
in the west of the Dharma punks, which
are Dharma punks, the Dharma punks.
So who are based here in La. Um, they,
they were like basically group of folks
that are my friends. They're, yeah,
they're our friends and uh, you
know, their whole s you know, they,
they have like major house parties
with huge, you know, music bands.
And do they do drugs? Um, that
movement? Not really. Well,
I think a lot of them had done a lot
of drugs and so part of the movement is
actually about being able to
be okay without the drugs.
And I think so that's part of the reason
a lot of people are attracted to that
movement. What about drinking? Uh,
we drink. Yeah. I had a glass of wine
a little bit. Or did you get hammered?
I don't really,
I don't get hammered.
So if someone's at the bar
and they pass your shot shots
don't like it. Don't like the
feeling. Yeah. It doesn't feel good.
I feel like crap afterwards.
Definitely afterwards. Yeah.
It's not the afterwards part.
Like how do you feel before,
how do you feel daring and
how you feel afterwards?
Like if I take the average of that, I
don't feel very good, so I don't tend to,
yeah,
that's personally don't tend to
boot. Koski uh, used to
get upset at stoners.
Duncan and I were talking about
this last night because they didn't
have to pay for the experience.
They didn't have the hangover.
The boot cows be Bukovsky felt like you
earned your drunk with the hangover.
You know,
he'd love that.
He loves the earth.
There's a hangover from being stoned.
It's just a little more subtle really.
You feel like that? Yeah, sure.
What do you feel like the hangover for
being stoned is? I don't feel it at all.
It's a,
it's a quality of,
of kind of a little bit slugginess of
the mind and have an increase in self
referencing talk for me like of of like
more like subtle fear and anxiety and
self preoccupation. Um, that's
what I've noticed in Wa.
That's fascinating.
Like in what way?
In in the sense that I described like,
you know,
after I've smoked marijuana,
like during its, you know,
it's an insightful opening experience,
but after there's a sense of kind of being
groggy and sludgy and like everything
is like less clear and less open than
before. And so there's a quality of,
of kind of like s like contraction
that comes after the expansion.
So that's what I would describe it.
It's a, it's like a mental contraction.
The headaches and the, no, it's not
as physical as alcohol. Do you guys
getting that North Carolina Week?
That's what's going on.
You've got to get some California weed.
Well you remember we lived in boulder,
so sativas right.
Oh you remember we lived in
Boulder, so we, we've, we've
tried all varieties. Yeah,
I'm sure. Maybe it's a physical thing
though. I don't experience that.
Maybe it's the mental training that we've
done and being a little more sensitive
to that.
I don't know.
No, I don't know. But I don't get sludgy
afterwards. There's no sludge. Enos.
Yeah. It could be personal
differences, but that's also
Endeca.
There's a just a job that which
is a wide margin by a wide margin.
The majority of what most people
are getting, it's easier to grow.
It's more more common and it's what
a lot of people are looking for.
It's got the more that narcotic effect,
whereas the sativas have more of
like an uplifting different sort of,
uh, and then there's also the eating of
it, which is much more introspective.
That turning much more cycle.
Much more psychedelic.
That's right. Yeah. I mean,
so personally I don't have anything
against a mind altering substances.
I think meditation is a
mind altering substance.
I'm more just curious about like
how do we use the substances?
Are we trying to get
away from our experience?
Are we trying to have insights every,
are we trying,
because the problem with
so many substances, you get
into a pattern of, of, of,
of really trying to cope with the
difficulty of experience and then getting
addicted to that state
as a way of dealing.
And I think that's where the problem
comes in from a kind of mind training and
contemplative perspective is like
that's a good way to describe it because
that is what sort of happens, right?
That's, that's why people get drunk.
That's why people do pills. Yeah.
It's like this,
this existence,
it's so confusing in itself that you just
want to escape and then you escape and
that escape becomes
a trap and you get locked in. Then you
have to keep getting the same thing.
Try it. If you stop, then you got to
deal with all this shit that comes up.
It doesn't feel good.
Yeah.
And then you got to go to Rehab and
try to wean your body off the escape.
And if you're a Buddhist teacher,
you got to be concerned about how
everyone perceives you because you're not
perfect.
It's cause you're all pilled
up. That's right. Yeah.
You can't have a pilled
up Buddhist teacher.
Is there any Buddhist teachers
that are all fucked up on Adderall?
Uh,
oh there,
there as many Buddhist teachers doing
as many weird things as there are
any other humans I'm pretty sure.
But wouldn't you hope that
at least overall there'd be
more improvement in their
overall character or ability
to cope with this existence?
I think there is overall,
I think people inclined towards openness
and then there's a balance between,
you know, the multiple levels
of development. I don't know,
meaning that, you know, just because
we develop and spiritual context.
Then you also have, you know,
your social context and um,
so we have to continue to develop evenly,
you know?
Yeah.
I think that's one of the trickiest
paradox is like you can become really good
at being in this free,
liberated, open, spacious mind.
Some people are incredibly good at it
and you'd just with them and you have a
hit of that, you know? But like their
sex life is completely messed up,
you know, and they like abuse
small dogs and children. And
really, I mean, I'm, I'm,
I'm a, I'm exaggerating a little
bit, not that much. I mean,
there are people who have had profound,
profound realizations of the
interconnection of all things and they're
profoundly dysfunctional and other levels.
And I've met many of
those folks and have been,
does folks at times you have
been those folks? Oh yeah.
I've been dysfunctional and you know,
messed up and doing stupid stuff
while you were practicing Buddhism.
Sure.
What was the influence that caused
you to be dysfunctional and fucked up
while your parents? Usually my,
the insights that have come from
Buddhism that direction.
So the insights that have,
they stabilized me really sure.
Sort of like a,
a psychedelic experience can
make someone go crazy permanently
or temporarily. Yeah, I think I've,
I've, I've gone through periods. I,
I'd say less.
It's been less the Buddhist meditation
as much as it's been like healing just
parts of my past, you know, being a human
and having been through difficult times,
you know, I think more of it's
probably been psychological.
And one of the common things that happens,
you know,
in a spiritual context is that people
use their spiritual practice to bypass
those human psychological issues.
It's called spiritual bypassing.
Um,
so for me,
I think part of what happened
is I bypassed for a long
time and rent really deep
in a particular way and then had to come
back around and deal with like my human
experience, uh, on, on a level
that I hadn't wanted to before.
And then it was really painful.
So it's almost like you have these sort
of confining aspects of your personality
that because of your perceptions,
those can finding aspects
are probably good.
And then Buddhism comes along and blows
down those boundaries and you're like,
I'm not ready for those yet.
And then you freak out for a little
bit and then you come back around.
Yeah.
And then the integration part I think is
kind of what you're talking about too,
is,
is going deep in the contemplative space.
And then if we're inclining
our minds towards, you know,
seeing the reality of like,
what's really happening here?
Like how are we constructing this reality?
And that starts to peel back. You know,
there are moments where it's like,
so there's a lot of freedom. And then
at the same time it's like, oh crap.
Like I got to figure out how to integrate
this in my life. And maybe that,
those insights of the vastness and
the spaciousness and that, you know,
we're not just our bodies and we're not
just our limited views of who we are.
You know,
those insights have to be integrated
into the way that we live our life.
And that's the challenging
part. That's when, you know,
the rubber meets the road
and, um, that, you know,
take psychological work. It takes
bodywork. It takes really, it's humbling.
It's very humbling because then at the
putting the teacher on the pedestal,
going back to that, it's like, oh, okay,
we're actually all in this together.
And you know, maybe, you
know, I've traveled these,
these entire worlds and can
help other people navigate them.
And at the same time, you know, we have to
come back as a collective and, and like,
you know what?
You got to wash the dishes.
He's got to take out the trash and then,
you know,
if you have kids you got
to raise the kids and um,
and how do you do that without, without
killing each other, you know? So
as more of our teachers,
Jack Kornfield says often you have to
remember your Buddha nature and your zip
code both and Ryan and the zip code
part I think can be hard if you've been
focusing mostly on,
on recognizing your,
your so called Buddha nature either like
the way that your mind inherently is.
Yeah. That's similarly disgust
in the psychedelic community.
Like what's the point in having these
experiences if you can't bring back the
revelations and enhance your actual
here and now life. Sure. Yeah.
Really important.
And then when it is integrated,
like I definitely want to flush this
out just a little bit more so people can
get the sense of that yes,
they're really their difficulties
and their beautiful, vast,
spacious moments.
And then at the same time,
and even if you don't have any beautiful
Spanish, I'd like vast spacious moments.
Even this moment in itself as you're
sitting here can be beautiful.
We've all touched into that.
You know, so it's like it,
there's a sense that when it's a
wearing out, that's how I describe it.
It's a wearing out process of
a smaller sense of who we are.
And that integration
process is not always easy.
And yet as it happens overall
and over the long run,
we are very, very, very
beautiful people. You know,
like there's that capacity to be
extremely powerful,
extremely beautiful and connected,
really connected with each
other. Um, and that's,
that's what inspires me
to talk about all of this.
So you, in a sense, you guys are
kind of Buddhist evangelists.
That's part of what you're doing.
Like in,
in the podcast you sort of
explaining or expressing,
how has this enhanced your life?
This is one way. It's, yeah, it's one,
it's one way to do it. I mean we're,
we're not evangelists in the,
in the sort of like missionary sense.
I think we're evangelist in
the sense that, you know,
we think there's value
here for some people,
for some of the time that are inclined
toward this or find it attractive.
And if they do, like we have, you know,
it's useful to be able to
connect with other folks who've,
who've done it and who in some sense
can, you know, can be there with you.
One of our, uh, one of our
mentors said, you know,
the role of a teacher is to be just a
little less afraid than the student.
Um, doesn't mean they're like,
have it completely figured out.
It just means they have a little
bit less fear of what's happening.
So I think it's useful to
connect with people like that.
If you find you're attracted
to something like that.
Like if you're in to psychedelics,
um, we've, we've explored
psychedelics, you know,
it's useful to go work with people who
know a bit about it and who can like, um,
not freak out if you have a bad trip
or if you start losing your, your mind,
you know,
that can like extend their stability to
you so that you can actually go through
that process and learn from it.
And in the end,
like have an empowering experience of it.
Uh,
or at least in an empowering like
interpretation of what happened. Um,
and instead of just feeling like, oh
my God, let reality sucks and like,
I'm just going to be depressed and, you
know, kind of crawl into a hole. Um,
so I think, you know, in the
same way, you know, for us,
we just want to create a space
where people can, um, you know,
practice together like, like they've
been doing for thousands of years,
sitting in exploring their minds in a,
in a collective,
well, I think you two are the comments
people I've ever had in the podcast.
This has been like the calmest
podcast ever. And, uh, I think, yeah,
in that sense, you guys are excellent
representations of the Buddhist lifestyle,
right? Cause that's what it's
all about, right? Being at peace,
sometimes being chilled sometimes,
unless you're a Dharma punk,
unless it, unless you're driving
up the four oh five, five o'clock,
that'll do it to you. That'll
definitely do it to you. Um,
thank you guys very much. It's been a lot
of fun, entertaining three hours and a,
if anybody wants to get
ahold of your podcast, uh,
your Twitter handle is Buddha
Geek, Buddhist Geeks, uh,
Emily Horn and Vincent Horn.
Those are your two individual
Twitter handles and your website,
Buddhist geeks.com and the podcast is
Buddhist geeks and available on Itunes,
all that jazz. Are you guys on
stitcher? Yes. Yes. Excellent.
And can you just, uh, do you have a, a
video aspect it or just a audio only?
We do a conference every year
and so we've recorded all of the
presentations@theconferenceanddupereleasethoseeventuallyhisvideostomillsonbuddhistgeeks.com.
Yeah. Okay. Terrific. Well, thank
you guys. Thank you very much.
It's been a lot of fun. Thank
you. Very interesting. Thank you.
Thanks to our sponsor.
Thanks to a legal zoom.com
go to legal zoom.com uh,
and use the Codeword Rogan at the referral
box at checkout to save yourself some
money.
Thanks also to blue apron,
go to blue apron.com
forward slash what is it?
Four slash Rogen blue apron.com forward
slash Rogan and get your first two meals
for free. We'll be back
tomorrow with standup comedian,
Nick Yousif and a lots
more podcast this week. So,
uh, take care and bye bye
for now. Big Cash Room.